Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Hast du dich jetzt schon in die äh Diaspora verabschiedet, ja?
Ich bin sofort geflohen.
Netzpolitik, die achtzigste Ausgabe Linus im Exil und äh ja, während also hier äh bereits die Zombiehorden durch die Straßen ziehen, Autos brennen, Barrikaden errichtet werden
wo die letzten Überlebenden noch äh sich versuchen, dem äh aufkommenden äh Ende entgegen zu stemmen,
Schaffen wir es dann doch noch äh die achtzigste Sendung äh zu machen. Äh jetzt ist Netzpolitik wohl offiziell tot und wir können uns unbedingt in ein Lokbuch Politik oder so, oder?
Ja, ich habe keine Ahnung, wo wo das, wo das jetzt wieder herkam,
aber das Wahlergebnis zeigt ja zumindest, dass äh das Themen der Netzpolitik und der Bürgerrechte jetzt ähm,
für die für die wählenden Personen keine äh ausschlaggebenden Themen waren.
Ja, zumindest nicht in einem Maße, dass es äh am Ende irgendwie zählbare Erfolge hätte. Ja, womit wir eigentlich auch schon äh bei unserem ersten Thema wären, oder?
Ja, es war Wahl.
Verwal.
Und es war eine Wahl, in der.
Also deren Ergebnis, ich weiß nicht, also was wäre, wir können ja mal überlegen, die kürzere Auflistung ist, welche Wahlergebnisse wären noch schlimmer gewesen? Also, ähm.
Noch schlimmer sein können.
Ehrlich gesagt, ich bin mir noch nicht so richtig sicher, äh was das Ergebnis so genau äh ist. Ja, vielleicht sollten wir erstmal hier äh festhalten. Heute ist äh Samstag
ausnahmsweise nehmen wir mal Samstag aus, der achtundzwanzigste äh September wäre vielleicht eh immer eine gute Idee, immer mal das Datum zu sagen. Hier.
Genau. Ich bin dann genereller Verpeiler, was äh Datennennungen betrifft. Jetzt haben wir es auf jeden Fall mal getan. Die Wahl ist also gerade mal knapp eine Woche äh her,
Und ich weiß noch, als so um achtzehn Uhr die Prognosen verlieren, äh verlesen wurden, da äh stockte dem einen oder anderen doch äh der Atem, entweder weil er sich äh vor Freude verschluckt hat, weil die FDP äh endlich aus dem Bundestag geflogen ist,
Oder weil äh einem in dem Moment dann äh schnell gewahr wurde, dass äh unser Wahl äh Recht,
so wie es dann eben angewendet wird bei so einer Stimmlage, dazu geführt hat, dass äh ein Großteil der Stimmen, also was ein nicht ein Großteil, ein großer Teil der Stimmen, nämlich ungefähr fünfzehn
Prozent an Parteien gegen dies letztlich nicht in den Bundestag geschafft haben, das ist meine Erkenntnis nach ein Rekord, so viel gab es noch nie.
So viel sonstiges und, und, und, und, und äh Versagen des ähm,
was wohl äh bedeutet, dass also mehrere Millionen abgegebene Stimmen wohlgemerkt,
letztlich nicht zur Verteilung der Sitze im Parlament herangezogen werden und dass die CDU mit ihren, was weiß, das Endergebnis zweiundvierzig irgendwas Prozent,
sehr nah an einer absoluten Mehrheit im Parlament, also eine absolute Mehrheit der Sitze im Parlament,
war. Das hatte so irgendwie keiner so recht äh vorhergesehen, interessant äh eigentlich, dass dass diese Spielart so überhaupt gar nicht in der Diskussion stand, zeigt wahrscheinlich, wie sie die Medien dann auch immer auf bestimmte,
Konstellationen äh sich fixieren, dass sie einfach andere Sachen nicht so recht sehen, aber da geht's gar nicht mal nur um die Medien. Ich denke, das ging irgendwie jedem irgendwie so.
Lass mich mal ganz kurz noch eins korrigieren, die CDU hat laut vorläufigen Ergebnis laut Bundeswahlleiter siebenunddreißig, dreiundsiebzig Komma zwei Prozent, also nicht zweiundvierzig, das war die erste Hochrechnung, glaube ich.
Bin hier im Bundeswahlleiter DE, vorläufiges Ergebnis der Bundestagswahl zweitausenddreizehn, CDU siebenunddreißig Komma zwei Prozent.
Das ist das Endergebnis.
Vorläufiges Endergebnis. Vorläufiges Ergebnis, keine Ahnung. Ja, die haben keine, die sind nicht über vierzig gekommen.
Also ich oder die äh Bundeswahlleiter macht hier äh killefit. Bundestagswahl zweitausenddreizehn.
Ja, du hast ja recht. Äh, nee, warte mal.
Die erste Hochrechnung waren bei zweiundvierzig Prozent, ja.
Also wir hatten vielleicht, das ist ja echt ganz interessant, einundsechzig Komma neun Millionen Wahlberechtigte und ähm,
Es gab in diesem Land eben sechzehn Komma zwei Millionen Menschen, die die CDU gewählt haben, zwölf Komma acht Millionen Menschen, die die SPD gewählt haben und immerhin noch eine knapp über eine Million Menschen, die die,
FDP gewählt haben.
Ja. Warte mal, es ist sogar noch anders, weil ich meine, du hast jetzt gerade die Erststimmen zitiert, ne?
Oh stimmt, ich habe die ah, ich habe die ah ja, genau, das ist die, das ist der Knick hier. Ach, was für ein Mist.
Bin ich denn komplett verdreht? Vierunddreißig Komma eins Prozent für die CDU.
In den Zweitstimmen.
Ja. Ist ja absurd. Das ist ja wirklich.
Aber das geht ja dann, dann ist ja die die Sitzverteilung ist ja dann also das was am Ende zählt ist die Sitzverteilung und da siehst du ja dann äh ich glaube das ist dann auch die Prozentzahl, die man dann am Ende äh.
Ja genau, das ist dann die Prozentzahl, die man eigentlich äh letztlich dann hat,
Interessanterweise wenn Sitzverteilung immer nur in absoluten Zahlen äh angegeben und keiner äh führt das mal in Prozente über, zumindest tut es der Bundeswahlleiter jetzt hier gerade nicht und man müsste mal selber äh rechnen, ja, die CDU hat,
zweihundertfünfundfünfzig äh Sitze, also hat sozusagen die acht Bit auch komplett ausgenutzt und äh.
Überhaupt sehr interessant. SPD ist auch irgendwie auf so einer schönen, binär,
Zahl hundertzweiundneunzig, die Linke vierundsechzig, die Grünen dreiundsechzig, also nahezu äh identisch? Ach so, und die CSU haben wir noch äh vergessen. Sechsundfünfzig.
Das heißt, wir müssen natürlich hier addieren, jetzt weiß ich auch, wo hier der Denkfehler äh die ganze Zeit liegt, also wir sind dann doch bei einundvierzig Komma fünf Prozent.
Also ich habe doch recht gehabt.
Du hast mich jetzt komplett äh verwirrt auf jeden Fall und äh wir haben uns jetzt hier schön bloß gestählt und jeder weiß, wie schlecht wir uns auf diese Sendung vorbereiten. Na, na toll.
Dreihundertelf Plätze an die Union und diese dreihundertelf,
ist deren Anteil an insgesamt sechshundertdreißig Sitzen und damit sind sie bei der Sitzplatzverteilung bei neunundvierzig Komma drei Prozent und können deshalb nicht,
die absolute Mehrheit für sich beanspruchen und die Nummer alleine wuppen in einer Koalition aus,
CDU und CSU, wobei das ja unsinnig, also bis auf dass die CSU halt.
Ja. Gut, also wahrscheinlich muss man dann doch da jetzt also wenn man diesen Autobauen Quatsch da gehört hat, dann sieht man doch, dass die CSU irgendwie verdient hat, eine andere Partei genannt zu werden.
Ähm.
So die Situation sich, die sich daraus aber jetzt ergibt, ist, was man jetzt auch mal sagen muss, Grüne, FDP und Linke, wenn man jetzt mal aus netzpolitischer Perspektive schaut und sagt, okay, das sind die Parteien.
Die zumindest irgendwie mal in Richtung Datenschutz äh Breitbandversorgung, Open Government irgendwie so eine Art progressive Haltung haben, ja?
Diese Parteien haben im Vergleich zu zweitausendneun.
Fünfzehn Prozent verloren. Also die die,
irgendwie Parteien, wo man sagen würde, die haben noch eine wünschenswerte ähm eine wünschenswerte, netzpolitische.
Perspektive unter ihren verschiedenen Perspektiven,
fünfzehn Prozent verloren. Dadurch, dass die FDP jetzt raus ist, ich hab natürlich haben alle sehr gejubelt und das.
Das oder haben sehr viele Menschen sehr gejubelt, dass äh dass die FDP jetzt aus dem aus dem Bundestag raus ist,
ähm wenn man sich jetzt das Personal der FDP anschaut, ist war das auch sicherlich eine,
unweigerliche Notwendigkeit, dass das man einfach dieses Theater nicht mehr mitmacht, so eine Partei in in einem, in einem Parlament zu dulden.
Ich persönlich muss auch sein, dass ich sehr traurig bin, weil wenn die wenn man diese dämliche FDP jetzt so, wenn die gerade es geschafft hätten, über die äh
über die Fünf-Prozent-Hürde zu kommen, dann hätte man eventuell die Sabine Leuthäuser Schnarrenberger als Justizministerin behalten können und das hätte uns einige der
Probleme, die wir jetzt in Zukunft erwarten müssen.
Ersparen können, wobei sich auch da die Frage stellt, ob man sich in einer Koalition ähm aus Union und FDP überhaupt noch mal eine ähm Sabine Leuthäuser Schnarrenberger geleistet hätte,
gehörig den Spaß weggenommen hat,
in den letzten Jahren. Ähm insofern okay, kann man sagen, ähm das wäre jetzt so der eine, dass der eine, der eine Wermutstropfen dessen, dass die FDP jetzt weg ist, es war nicht alles schlecht. Und ähm aber ähm,
Ja, wie gesagt, die Frage ist, ob sie ob die Union sich die äh äh die Schnarre nochmal geleistet hätte.
Ja gut, die Frage wäre, ob die FDP sich das geleistet hätte, weil letztlich ist es ja in ihr die Minister zu bestellen, da hat die Kanzlerin sicherlich noch irgendwas mitzureden, aber die Frage ist jetzt auch müßig, äh das äh,
ihre das ist ja komplett unbestritten aber sie war ja nun auch innerhalb der FDP im Prinzip eine komplette Insel, ja? Also das,
ähm war einfach diese,
die Partei schon fast nicht mehr wert. Gewisser Hinsicht, denke ich, ist das auch eine Chance. Ähm keine Ahnung, wie sich das jetzt so entwickelt, aber diese neoliberalen äh verpeilten,
Kräfte da in der FDP, die haben jetzt auf jeden Fall einen Dämpfer erhalten. Ob jetzt die FDP vorhat, sich quasi über so einen wirklich äh liberales Profil wieder neu zu erfinden.
In ihrer Wahlanalyse dürfte ihnen ja auch äh auffallen, dass irgendwie zwei Prozent auch an die Piraten gegangen sind. Das hätte ihnen auch schon mal helfen können, so ein Wählerpotenzial. Nicht, dass äh ich sagen möchte, von diesen zwei Prozent sind alles potenzielle FDP-Wähler, aber äh,
Wir kennen, glaube ich, beide genug Beispiele von Leuten, die sehr wohl äh gesagt haben, ich wähle auch FDP wegen dieses äh liberalen Anstrichs durch Wähler auch äh durch wie wenig Leute er auch immer vertreten,
sein würde, die dann eben auch gesagt haben, okay, dann halt jetzt mal Piraten. Für die hat's auch nicht gereicht, da sollten wir auch gleich nochmal drüber reden. Aber bleiben wir vielleicht nochmal erstmal bei dieser äh Gesamtmengelage.
Befindet sich ja die, die ganze Diskussion natürlich in der Frage, okay, die CDU hat jetzt keine Mehrheit.
Das wird ja gerne übersehen, ja? Also ich meine, Wahlsieger, okay, kann man ja so sagen und jeder sieht es als vollkommen selbstverständlich an, dass äh Merkel jetzt Kanzlerin bleibt,
Ja, das wird überhaupt nicht auch nur im geringsten in Zweifel gezogen. Und das, obwohl sie überhaupt gar keine Mehrheit hat.
Das war ja schon mit äh in der Elefantenrunde mit dem äh besoffenen Gerhard Schröder. Äh der Punkt, dass man sagt, die stärkste Fraktion stellt oder die stärkste Partei stellt.
Also die stärkste Fraktion stellt traditionell den oder die Kandidatin für das Kanzleramt.
Ja, was heißt, stellt traditionell, also in einer Koalition, ja also in aber das heißt ja noch lange nicht, dass jetzt die stärkste Partei auch immer den Kanzler gestellt hätte.
Du sprichst auf das, du sprichst auf den Umstand an, dass äh,
eine wie immer im äh wenn ich das jetzt richtig sehe im Bundestag eine oder wie immer in letzter in letzten in letzter Zeit eine linke Mehrheit gibt,
Weil wir eine SPD haben, die ähm.
Kategorisch seit jeher ähm die Koalition mit jenen ähm ausschließt, die äh ihre Werte, die ursprünglichen Werte der SPD weiterpflegen.
Steht diese steht jetzt eine rot-rot-grüne Koalition nicht irgendwie zur Debatte.
Ja, ich meine, man kann lange darüber diskutieren, ob die, ob sich bei der SPD jetzt wirklich im Kern um eine äh linke Partei handelt, ja, ich denke, sie ist im Wesentlichen und sieht sich auch selber so, äh, quasi als Volkspartei oder Partei der Mitte oder welchen.
Welche Formel man auch immer äh da äh sucht, um das korrekt zu umschreiben, wofür die SPD tatsächlich steht, gar keine Frage, ist sie äh links verankert, ja, aber äh zumindest nicht so so sehr, dass sie sich selber jetzt als eine Kernlinke
Partei äh selbst bezeichnet.
Die SPD was macht die SPD also die SPD ich bitte dich,
Sie muss doch nun mal irgendwie in selbst wenn sie eine Volkspartei sein will, muss sie doch irgendeine Form von Profil gegenüber der CDU vertreten.
Das hat sie in den letzten acht Jahren nicht getan.
Mindestens und und in den Jahren davor hat sie ähm also hör mir auf. Also wer die SPD das.
Der Laden wird ja jetzt einfach das das Ding wird selbst ohne politische Erwägung. Wenn man jetzt nur mal politisch also ohne politisch inhaltliche Erwägung, wenn man nur mal strategisch denkt,
macht die SPD das doch seit ich weiß ich nicht wie langer Zeit jetzt schon falsch ja? Also das.
Da fällt mir nichts mehr, fällt mir nichts mehr zu ein. Man kann jetzt nur man kann jetzt nur hoffen.
Also stellen wir uns mal die Frage. So die naheliegendste, naheliegendste Koalitionsoption ist jetzt eigentlich dass es wieder eine große Koalition gibt.
Diese große Koalition in ist 'ne Option, da gibt's für die SPD nichts zu gewinnen, gar nichts.
Kann sich nur wieder also.
Frau Ministerposten.
Haben irgendwie einen Ministerposten und einen Dienstwagen, ähm aber letztendlich wird diese Partei, würde diese Partei damit, sagen wir mal,
mindestens acht bis äh zwölf Jahre CDU Regierung zementieren. Sie hatte keinerlei Chance äh in in vier Jahren einen Wahlkampf gegen die CDU zu machen,
und dann müssten mindestens nochmal vier Jahre CDU-Regierung sein, bis die SPD,
theoretisch eine Möglichkeit hätte, das irgendwie mal langsam die Leute äh da keinen Bock mehr drauf haben. Und wahrscheinlich würden sie halt auch noch versemmeln. Deswegen echt, also acht bis zwölf Jahre CDU sind uns gewiss,
wenn die, wenn die SPD sich jetzt zu einer großen.
Koalition entscheidet. Da haben sie jetzt auch mal halbwegs vernünftig gemacht. Der der Steinburg zieht sich äh zurück, wie jetzt im Rahmen des SPD Konvents. Äh verlautbart wurde und ähm ob sie
warte mal, wie war das, wenn was das wurde jetzt gestern Abend da verkündet, sie wollen also ähm.
Sondierungsgespräche machen, das ist ja auch in Ordnung, das finde ich auch gut, ne. Es war Wahl und dann wird unterhalten sich die Parteien miteinander.
Unter welchen Umständen und Vorzeichen sie denn bereit wären, zum Beispiel in Koalitionsverhandlungen einzutreten
und ähm was die SPD jetzt vorhat, ist äh Sondierungsgespräche führen und dann äh mit dem Ergebnis dieser Sondierungsgespräche zurück in den in die in den,
Parteikonvent gehen und dort die Entscheidung treffen, ob sie Koalitionsverhandlungen aufnehmen wollen.
Koalitionsgespräche. Das finde ich erstmal okay so. Äh man kann hoffen, dass äh dass die SPD dann einfach aus die SPD-Basis, aus aus Selbsterhaltungstrieb sagt, nein.
Keine Koalitionsgespräche, noch nicht mal Koalitionsgespräche, wir koalieren nicht mit der CDU in einer großen Koalition. So, wer zu hoffen ähm.
Wie wahrscheinlich das ist, weiß ich nicht. So, dann gibt's äh,
Ich glaube, die CDU hat noch nicht mal eine Koalition mit der Linkspartei kategorisch ausgeschlossen. Das weiß einfach jeder, dass das nicht passieren wird. Ähm und ähm das heißt, es bleibt dann äh die Option äh schwarz-grün.
Ich hatte das ja schon vor einigen Sendungen mal angedeutet, das ist was, was wir früher oder später auf Bundesebene irgendwann mal sehen werden,
Ich zittere davor, dass es äh dieses Mal schon der Fall sein wird, gibt's natürlich äh relativ viel ähm Gegenwind auch innerhalb der Grünen.
Aber natürlich ist schwarz-grün eine rechnerische Option und früher oder später äh wird die grüne Partei auch soweit sein, dass sie das auf einer Bundesebene macht.
Ja, aber ich meine das, wenn schon die SPD über eine Mitgliederbefragung äh äh nachdenkt, dann äh wird es bei den Grünen unmöglich sein, äh über irgendeinen anderen Weg äh so etwas abzusegnen und das kann ich mir zumindest für zwanzig dreizehn.
Vorstellen. Also das würde mich wirklich komplett.
Ja lass vorstellen kann man sich eigentlich gar nichts. So jetzt dann gibt's natürlich noch die theoretische Option äh Minderheitsregierung mit wechselnden Mehrheiten. Wäre doch mal eine ganz spannende Sache.
Eigentlich die bestmögliche Lösung.
Aber die das birgt natürlich ein großes äh,
Risiko der äh Handlungsunfähigkeit oder der äh Erpressbarkeit der äh CDU, insbesondere, weil ja dann theoretisch SPD, Linke und Grüne doch ähm.
Quasi äh also sollten sich dann sollten SPD, Grüne und Linke äh so schlau sein, sich dann vernünftig gegen die äh CDU zu verbünden. Ähm.
Wäre da die Handlungsfähigkeit natürlich schon erstmal relativ eingeschränkt.
Ja, Stichwort Mindestlohn.
Risiko eingehen, ja.
Stichwort Mindestlohn, wie das ja äh Gysi jetzt auch schon ganz äh feixend äh da.
Gleich vorne eingestellt hat mit, würde ja eh lange dauern, bis jetzt hier eine Koalition kommt, da könnten wir ja mal den Mindestlohn beschließen,
Da war doch die SPD immer dafür, die Grünen auch, die Linke auch, Holla! Äh, ja.
Ja und ich freue mich halt auf also das macht mich wirklich so fertig. Also dass die SPD,
nur weil Oscar Lafontaine ihnen mal den Stinkefinger äh gezeigt hat, immer noch die beleidigte Leberwurst spielt und der Meinung ist, sie könnte jetzt auf Bundesebene etwas nicht tun, was sie auf Landesebene schon seit vielen Jahrzehnten,
viele Jahrzehnte ist etwas übertrieben seit vielen Jahren, also schon seit Jahrzehnten tut,
ne, nämlich auch mit den Linken sich auf ein pragmatisches Bündnis zu einigen. Ich meine, wenn das in Berlin geklappt hat, wenn das in Brandenburg geklappt hat, in vielen anderen äh Ostländern geklappt hat, warum soll das auf Ost-Ebene äh auf Bundesebene nicht auch,
funktioniert. Können wir einfach keiner klar machen. Ja, okay, die mögen sich nicht, bla, bla, bla, aber das jetzt irgendwie die CSU und äh der linke Flügel der SPD sich jetzt so besonders lieb haben, das sehe ich halt auch nicht.
Die haben einfach so viele Jahre jetzt inzwischen auf ähm,
die äh Linkspartei eingedroschen, ja, also als sie noch äh WASG hieß, ähm als sie den Zusammenschluss mit der äh mit der PDS ging und um sich dann Linkspartei zu nennen, die haben.
So viele Jahre versucht, das Projekt Linkspartei irgendwie totzukloppen, weil sie ja wussten, dass das im Prinzip ihre ihre Wähler sind, die dahin abwandern und zwar ausschließlich.
Ähm dass sie natürlich jetzt einen Glaubwürdigkeitsproblem bekämen, ähm wenn sie das.
Wenn sie das, wenn sie das jetzt irgendwie diesen Kurs ändern und das konnten sie konnten sie theoretisch nicht machen, ohne dass sie vollends dafür aufs Maul bekommen hätten in den,
in den Medienthemen. Ähm früher später werden sie diesen Schritt aber machen müssen und ich hoffe, dass sie's äh, dass sie spätestens jetzt,
endlich auf den auf den Gedanken kommen, dass sie mal vor einer Wahl nicht äh äh Koalitionen mit irgendjemandem ausschließen,
ähm ich denke, sie wollten.
Unter anderem dadurch ähm den Effekt erziehen, dass sie sagen, wir werden nicht mit denen koalieren, damit jeder, der eventuell auf äh rot-rot und äh beziehungsweise rot rot grün äh gesetzt hat,
dann im Zweifelsfall doch die SPD wählt, ja, aber diese gesamte Taktiere ist alles es ist alles Mist, ähm die SPD wird.
Meiner Erwartung nicht mehr zu irgendeiner Bedeutung äh gelangen, die sie sich gerne für sich selber wünscht, ohne das Problem äh Linkspartei oder die Lehren,
die die Linkspartei ihnen jeden Tag lehrt irgendwann mal für sich anzunehmen.
Das sehe ich ähnlich.
Jetzt haben wir nämlich das eigentlich große Problem, nämlich wenn es jetzt wirklich mit der Union und der SPD zu einer äh großen Koalition kommt, da kann man dann auch mal einfach mal auch den Begriff große Koalition mal wieder neu fassen, weil
Diesmal wäre damit nicht äh also damit wäre nicht nur eine Zweidrittelmehrheit für eine Verfassungsänderung
problemlos herstellbar, ja? Weil,
Wenn man jetzt in Richtung Vorratsdatenspeicherung denken und so weiter, permanent, weil die CDU Gesetze beschließen, die an den äh an der Verfassung scheitert, dann wäre es ja so dann nochmal sehr naheliegend, einfach mal die Verfassung zu ändern.
Ja, okay, das wäre jetzt noch das das wäre so das erste Teil, Traumszenario.
Ja, ich meine, wir wissen ja, wie wie stabil die SPD äh in dieser Fragestellung äh sich äh erwiesen hat und äh glaube mir wohl nicht ernsthaft, dass die SPD jetzt auf einmal äh ihren linken Widerstandsgeist äh ausgerechnet in einer Koalition mit einer starken CDU wieder entdeckt
und dann irgendwie auf äh äh aufschaltet und sagt so, nein, mit uns äh keine Änderung der Vorratsdatenspeicherung,
wenn die sofort einknicken, ne.
In dem Fall sowieso nicht. Was sie hätten, wenn ich das jetzt richtig äh zusammenrechnet hätte zweihundertfünfundfünfzig CDU-Sitze hundertzweiundneunzig SPD-Sitze sechsundfünfzig CSU-Sitze und damit dreiundachtzig Prozent der Sitze.
Genau, das ist nämlich die nächste interessante Hürde, die hier überschritten wird, ist nämlich die fünfundsiebzig Prozent Grenze. Die spielt nämlich im äh in der Geschäftsordnung des Bundestags auch noch eine sehr wichtige Rolle mit einer Regierung, die über fünfundsiebzig Prozent der Sitze hätte,
ist es noch nicht mal möglich für die Opposition einen Untersuchungsausschuss zu beantragen.
Das muss ich sagen, gerade im Hinblick auf die letzten Jahre, ja, mit NSU, et cetera, was da alles äh vorgefallen ist und überhaupt den Filz, den man äh erwarten darf, bei äh so einer Regierung. Äh ich meine, das ist,
Einheitspartei, das ist ja irgendwie die Partei hat immer Recht, ja? Dann sind die Grünen und, und, und die Linke können sich das als Blockparteien titulieren und dann haben wir da irgendwie unsere Volksvertretung,
Also das, das ist für mich das totale Horrorszenario. Diese schwarz-grüne Koalition, diese schwarz-rote äh Koalition, die sich jetzt,
Ich weiß nicht, ob sie sich schon abzeichnet, ne, aber sie schwebt im Raum, so. Man man riecht den, den, den Mief, den sie jetzt schon äh verstrahlt und muss sagen, ich
bei nichts schüttele ich jetzt mehr den Kopf als so bei solchen Umfragen wie, na ja, fünfzig Prozent der Deutschen sind dafür, ja, für eine schwarz-rote Koalition.
In ihrem fortgesetzten Waren von, keine Ahnung, alles muss immer möglichst durch so viele Leute, die sie schon kennen aus dem Fernsehen äh vertreten sein, ohne die Konsequenzen dessen äh,
zu lesen und fünfundsiebzig Prozent Hürde, eine Regierung ohne ähm Untersuchungsausschuss äh,
aus der Opposition und hat äh noch so eine zweite äh ähm es gibt so noch eine zweite Sache, die nicht möglich ist. Es ist nicht nur die.
Untersuchungsausschüsse, was war denn das andere, was nicht nicht mehr möglich ist, mit einer fünfundzwanzig unter unter fünfundzwanzig Prozent Opposition,
nochmal äh rausschauen, da gab's einen interessanten äh Artikel drüber im Spiegel.
Ähm Gisi hat wohl auch schon äh gesagt, man sollte doch vielleicht die Geschäftsordnung äh noch ein weiteres Mal äh ändern,
dahingehend, wenn das passieren sollte, sollte, dass man eben sagt, äh wenn die Opposition geschlossen für einen Untersuchungsausschuss stimmt, dann hat es auch durchzugehen unabhängig davon wie viel,
sind, weil es war nämlich früher schon mal so, dass diese Grenze bei einem Drittel des äh des Bundestags lag, tatsächlich, also es waren mal dreiunddreißig Komma drei Prozent,
erforderlich, bis es dann halt große Koalition gab, die eben diese
zwei Drittel äh Grenze auch wiederum überschritten hat und man sich eigentlich in der selben Situation befand und damals ist halt dann äh dieser dieser Einstiegshürde auf fünfundzwanzig Prozent gesenkt worden. Und jetzt befinden wir uns halt am Punkt mit einer siebzehn Prozent äh also einer potenziellen siebzehn Prozent Opposition
dasselbe Problem auch wieder äh droht. Also es ist.
Also lieber schwarz-grün als äh schwarz-rot?
Ähm also.
Ja, also ich meine Schwarz-Grün wäre mal insofern sehr interessant, ja
Im Hinblick auf die äh großen äh zahlreichen Abgänge, die aber die Grünen jetzt schon angekündigt haben, glaube ich nicht, dass das auch nur irgendeine Chance hätte. Weil wenn äh sowas zustande kommen soll, dann müssten sie ja Trittin äh
sofort wieder ausmotten, weil ohne Trittin.
Ja also ohne sagen wir mal etablierte äh äh Regierungserfahrende Kämpfer werden die Grünen ja komplett durch
Ich meine, die können jetzt nicht die Leute aus der zweiten Reihe holen und da in Ministerränge reinkleiden und dann sollen die mal eben da äh am Kabinettstisch äh grüne Politik durchsetzen, ja? Unmöglich. Also da, da, da, da, dazu musst du, müsste man wahrscheinlich sogar den den Fischer ausmotten. Ich meine, der wird sich.
Scheiß drum kehren so aber das ist im Prinzip das Gewicht, was was die Grünen an der Stelle bräuchten und das sehe ich halt eigentlich nur in Form von,
Kynastrittin, die jetzt einfach reihenweise gesagt haben, nö, ich mache jetzt hier mal Vize äh Präsident im Bundestag. Das soll ja auch ein ganz guter Job sein.
Treten sich ja schon gegenseitig auf die Füße. Ist schon so ein bisschen äh interessant, wie sehr die jetzt alle schon irgendwie im Pensionsmodus äh gegangen sind, ne.
Schwarz-Grün fände ich zwar irgendwie auch mal ganz äh lustig so, ja, also das würde ich mir gerne mal angucken, was dabei eigentlich tatsächlich rauskommt, weil das war früher immer der Schreckgespenst, der äh Konservativen,
mittlerweile haben sie irgendwie erkannt, dass sie da so sich so unehnlich ja auch nicht sind. Äh das würde ich aber gerne mal platzen sehen so erstmal, ja?
Es wäre auf jeden Fall sehr interessant da drauf zu hauen, aber mit der SPD, aufgrund der Zahlenverhältnisse, das wäre definitiv das Schlimmste. Schwarz-linke ist natürlich vollkommen ausgeschlossen und insofern,
kann ich einfach nur sagen, warum sollte man nicht äh einfach rot-rot-grün gehen? Ja, ich seh's nicht. Wenn jetzt die SPD sagt, wir haben keine Angst vor Neuwahlen.
Ja, das ist, da genau, da kommt jetzt der Punkt. Also, es gibt ja Stimmen, die sagen, warum nicht äh warum nicht? Ähm warum nicht? Ähm
Minderheitenregierung. Da könnte die CDU natürlich sehr schön so, dann würde sie mal was mit der, mit den Grünen machen, mal was mit der SPD oder was auch immer, ne, würde sie irgendwie
wechselnde Mehrheiten sich irgendwie suchen. Das wäre sicherlich auch mal ein sehr lebendige Demokratie.
Ja, das stimmt.
Unter Umständen hätte die sogar ein sehr äh irgendwie sehr ein Ergebnis also politisches Ergebnis, was vielleicht sogar sehr befriedigend.
Wäre für viele Menschen und dann beim nächsten Mal, wenn er rein ähm einer reinen schwarzen Regierung, die zur absoluten Mehrheit verhelfen würde. Ähm.
Gibt dann noch diese Option. Jetzt ich hatte mir das rausgesucht, das ist ein etwas komplizierterer Prozess, aber sagen wir mal Neuwahlen, ne? Also äh es ist ja dann, glaube ich, so wie wie läuft dieser Prozess der Bundes nee, der das Parlament schlicht dem Bundespräsidenten erkannt?
Ein Kanster vor oder nee, der Kanzler den Bundes, der,
Der Bundespräsident, dem Parlament, das Parlament stimmt drüber ab, da macht man irgendwie dreimal mit verschiedenen Mehrheits und sonst was Regeln und Pipapo. Wenn nicht, ich,
wie gesagt, Prozedere ist mir nicht ganz äh bin ich mir nicht ganz im Klaren, aber letztendlich könnte dann der Bundespräsident Neuwahlen äh anordnen,
dann könnte man meinen, dann könnte, würde man ja eventuell hoffen, dass die dass die Bevölkerung äh die Wahlberechtigte Bevölkerung sagt, ach, guck mal,
So ein Mist kommt dabei raus, dann überlegen wir uns das jetzt mal anders und wählen vernünftig.
Aber das ist äh auch nicht der Fall. Also was man äh was was äh entsprechende ähm was entsprechende äh Umfragen dann zeigen, ist, dass sich vermutlich nicht wenig einem äh an dem ähm.
Also Neuwahlen.
An dem Wahlergebnis ändern würde.
Neuwahlen in drei Monaten würde uns vermutlich wieder die FDP in den Bundestag holen.
Die bis dahin ihre ganzen ja Affentheater komplett abgesetzt haben, ja? Ich meine ist schon so gut wie äh,
gegangen. Auch da werden sie sich diverse Altlasten mal entledigen. Dann haben sie irgendwie hier diesen charmanten Lindner aus äh NRW dann äh an die Stelle geholt, der dann irgendwie blond äh fröhlich lächelnd sagt, jetzt sind wir wieder äh lieb,
Ja und äh jetzt habt ihr euch mal äh uns mal ordentlich auf den Popo gehauen. Und ehrlich gesagt, diese null Komma zwei Prozent, die sie ihnen dann noch fehlen,
Wie werden sie zu dem Zeitpunkt dann wieder locker eingespielt haben? Ja, AfD hin, AfD Herr,
dass denke ich mal wäre dann so ein Automatismus. Ob die AfD die Nummer so durchziehen kann und dann noch mehr Leute bekommt, keine Ahnung,
Kann sein, kann nicht sein, weiß ich nicht, unklar,
kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass die Grünen sonderlich profitieren werden, weil sie in dem Moment ähm
noch nicht mal ihr vertrautes Personal am Start haben und quasi noch überhaupt gar keine Zeit hatten, äh irgendwelches neues Vertrauen in die äh neue Personalkonstellation äh aufzubauen und was soll bitte die SPD aus dem Hut zaubern?
Deswegen hat keiner von denen Interesse an Neuwahlen.
Genau, also dieses, wir haben keine Angst vor Neuwahlen, klingt für mich so ein bisschen wie das Pfeifen im Walde.
Ja, weil äh ich sehe nicht so richtig, äh mit welcher Position die SPD später darstellen soll. Das sieht dann für mich wieder ganz nach schwarz-gelb aus,
Weil dann die äh CDU wiederum nicht diesen Vorteil hat, äh wie jetzt, dass sie eben,
überproportional von ihrem Stimmergebnis profitiert, weil so viele Leute an der fünf Prozent Hürde, also so viel Parteien, an der Fünf-Prozent-Hürde gescheitert sind. Also,
ja? Manchmal wär's mir fast lieber gewesen, die CDU hätte jetzt diese letzten zwei, drei Sitze auch noch bekommen.
Weil damit wäre dann zumindest mal die Hackordnung klar gewesen. Ja, also dann wäre einfach klar, äh die CDU ist an allem schuld.
So
Ja
Und äh man hätte eine klare, eine starke, man hätte eine eine echt starke Opposition, ja, die so achtundvierzig Prozent
ähm des Bundestages ausmacht, die alles Mögliche äh
tun kann, genug Manpower hat, auch Gegenentwürfe zu liefern, die auch im Zweifelsfall mit ein paar äh CDU-Umfallern in wirklich kritischen Diskussionen dann auch mal das Ruder rumreißen kann. Das wäre spannend, ja. Ähm so mit äh schwarz-rot
das ist einfach, das ist einfach die schlecht möglichste äh Konstellation, die ich mir überhaupt irgendwie vorstellen könnte und äh das kann einfach nur ins Verderben führen. Also von daher ist das Ergebnis einfach wirklich.
Schlicht so, ne.
Du denn, hast du denn äh also ich würde jetzt nochmal gerne kurz, auch wenn ich das,
einfach nochmal kurz die die Parteien auch nochmal von das netzpolitischer Perspektive beleuchten, weil wir ja sagen, also unabhängig von dem von dem allgemeinen Koalitionsgerät, der da jetzt ist es äh für die Netzpolitik besonders schlecht, aber hast du
Ich habe das, ich muss jetzt sagen, ich ich habe ja keinen Fernseher, ich gucke keinen Fernsehen. Und gestern rauschte dann dieses Video an mir vorbei, wie die Union.
Ähm auf dieser Bühne steht und den Toten Hosensong singt? Hast du das gesehen?
Welchen Toten Hosensong?
An Tagen wie diesen.
Nee, habe ich nicht gesehen.
Die haben Tim.
Ich sage jetzt nur, also eine eine spontan Wummitation ist garantiert du schaust dir das an. Da da stehen die auf der Bühne,
das steht die die Merkel.
Von der Leyen und versuchen irgendwie dann da mitzuklatschen, weil sie das ja so auf ihren Schützenfesten lernen, dass wenn Musik läuft man im vier vier Etakt mitklatscht,
und der Kauder brüllt da irgendwie ins Mikrofon und der äh Pofalla steht in der zweiten Reihe und grinst wie ein Honigkuchenpferd und die singen diesen Song an Tagen wie diesen von den Toten Hosen. Das ist,
Es ist also.
Einmal gesehen wird, kann nicht entsehen werden, aber du kriegst das, du kriegst die kalte, spontanen Gummi dazu, wenn du das siehst. Es war wirklich vollständig.
Es war ich mir fällt da nichts mehr zu ein. Es ist unglaublich und ich ich hoffe ja eigentlich, ne? Also wenn man das jetzt mal zeigt, wenn man einfach nur zeigt so, guck mal.
Jetzt gehen wir nochmal wählen, ja? Dass man damit vielleicht irgendwie was bewegen könnte. Aber es ist halt nicht so. Und das macht mir Sorge, das macht mir echt Sorge.
Aha, also ich äh blättere hier gerade mal in den Lyrics, das ist schon ein bisschen beunruhigend, ne?
Tagen wie diesen wünscht man sich Unendlichkeit, an Tagen wie diesen haben wir noch ewig Zeit. In dieser Nacht der Nächte, die uns so viel verspricht, erleben wir das Beste, kein Ende ist in Sicht.
Du musst du musst das Bild dazu sehen, du musst das Bild dazu sehen und äh es ist also es ist.
Fremdschämen, Fremdschämen Deluxe, ja.
Gar nichts. Da leere, innere Leere. Es ist nichts. Du empfindest.
Es ist unvorstellbar. Es ist, es ist wirklich unglaublich. Na ja, also das muss man echt nicht gesehen haben, also allein, also das das wird mich.
Ich habe ähm gut, also was lassen wir das? Ähm.
Das hier schon, ich seh's hier grade.
Du kriegst, also mach es nicht, du musst dir vorher dein Zimmer mit mit Planer auslegen. Also die CDU.
Ja, ich sage nur Rocconi, ne.
Ich was was ist mit Rocco Schamoni?
Du wählst CDU und darum mach ich Schluss.
Eigentlich immer wieder das Lied, was man spielen muss am Schluss, wenn man irgendwie besoffen auf dem Boden liegt, weil man das Wahlergebnis nicht vertragen hat.
Unerträglich. Also CDU, was, was war, was haben wir denn ähm jetzt mal Ausblick auf die nächsten Jahre? Da gibt's ähm.
Also nur mal auf die Wahlversprechen, so ein bisschen auf Wahlversprechen und das, was wir von den Parteien wissen, habe ich mal ein bisschen mir hier,
äh zusammengeschrieben. CDU irgendwie sagt was ja, es muss irgendwie mehr Internet geben, sie hat sich,
bekennt sich trotz äh Snowden weiterhin zur äh Vorratsdatenspeicherung und will die durchknallen. Sie hat keine Netzneutralität gefördert,
Sagt aber, man müsste unter Umständen mal gucken, ob man da eventuell vielleicht was machen müsste. Sie hat in ihrem ähm,
ähm in ihrem Wahlprogramm stehen, dass sie Deutschland als Datenstandort äh internationale Attraktivität äh garantieren möchte, was für Datenschutzfragen keine besonders äh,
gute keine für gute ähm keine besonders gute Aussicht stellt. Äh wir kennen die ganze netzsperren Thematik, wir kennen die Staats äh Trojaner-Thematik. Das ist jetzt eine Partei, die annähernd äh.
'ne absolute Mehrheit im Bundestag hat. Die SPD wir kennen das fordert ja die Vorratsdatenspeicherung mit menschlichen Antlitz.
Sie plant da die äh Reform auf äh EU-Ebene und ähm hat dann in ihrem Wahlprogramm diesen besonders äh.
Besonders kompetenten Satz stehen, den Umgang mit Verbindungsdaten werden wir auf die Verfolgung schwerster Straftaten beschränken, die Datenarten und Speicherdauer hinsichtlich ihrer Eingriffsintensität differenzieren und Regelung,
einfach und zukunftsfähig fassen. Man sieht, dieser Satz zeigt schon, wie klar einfach und zukunftsfähig sie äh sich ausdrücken können. Ähm,
wenn die bis heute nicht verstanden haben, dass wenn ich die gesamte Bevölkerung überwache.
Der Sinn, der der Satz, wir beschränken das auf äh schwere schwerste Straftaten,
keinen Sinn ergibt. Das haben sie vorher nicht verstanden. Insofern, da ist auch keine Hoffnung. Also, SPD ist
sie wollen da eventuell ein bisschen regeln und aus sechs Monaten nur drei machen oder was auch immer für einen Unsinn sie sich da ausdenken, um den Drops irgendwie äh in den Rachen zu drücken,
Sie sagen immerhin, sie wollen äh Netzneutralität und irgendwie ein Breitbandausbau ähm,
haben aber allerdings, und das fände ich jetzt spannend, die haben ja im Wahlkampf Pofalla und Friedrich gut einen eingeschüttet und haben die ganze Zeit gepoltert vom größten Überwachungsskandal der Menschheit und siehe da, sie hatten Recht und äh man könnte sich natürlich jetzt ähm.
Fragen, ob ob sie ob eventuell äh in in Sachen,
also in einer schwarz-roten Koalition in Sachen NSA-Affäre irgendwie eine Form von Wind
wehen könnte. Aber wenn man sich dann überlegt, wie die SPD die Bestandsdatenauskunft durch den Bundesrat gewunken hat. Damals, als sie die Gelegenheit hatte, das zu verhindern.
Ähm und wenn man sich überhaupt so den Track Record der SPD in Sachen Wert uns verraten anschaut
bleibt er trotzdem nicht großartige Hoffnung, man sieht Steinbrück nimmt jetzt seinen Hut, die Partei hat immer noch zweiundzwanzig oder sonst was Prozent, die man zerstören kann und wir werden sehen, wie lange wie lange sie dafür noch brauchen,
FDP, wie gesagt, man wähnt, man weint ihr eigentlich keine Tränen nach, netzpolitisch aber ist das Ausscheiden der FDP oder ist überhaupt diese neue,
sagen wir mal vielleicht nicht das Ausscheiden der FDP, aber das Ende dieser Legislaturperiode mit dem Verlust von Sabine Leuthäuser Schnarrenberger äh fürchterliches äh
etwas fürchterliches. Sie hat irgendwie sich gegen Webschweren ausgesprochen, sie hat gegen die Freestrikes äh gekämpft, wie haben's ihr zu verdanken, dass wir bis heute keine Vorratsdatenspeicherung haben? Die hat ja kompletten Unfrieden in dieser äh Regierung gestiftet und wenn man einen Menschen,
wenn man einen Menschen findet in in der in der vergangenen Bundesregierung, den man irgendwie äh Respekt zollen sollte, dann ist das oft äh sicherlich sie.
Ja, er kann sich eine neue Partei suchen, irgendwie auch verschiedene zur Auswahl. Das wäre ja auch nochmal nett.
Ich.
Ich weiß, ich ich glaube, solchen solchen rationalen Entscheidungen und solchen sinnvollen, rationalen Entscheidungen steht im Wege, dass die Parteien äh,
immer zu laut poltern über verschiedene Personen, ja? Die sich immer auch äh weiß ich nicht, ja ne,
so Personen zur Non-Grata machen und ähm.
Dann ähm sich leicht angreifbar machen auf dem Flügel sich dann unglaubwürdig zu machen, wenn sie andere Personen aufnehmen oder so oder wenn man da mal also schwierig, ne, solche solche Gesinnungswechsel,
vermeintliche Gesinnungswechsel von Personen werden dann in der Regel medial sehr sehr.
Ähm ja, sehr, sehr übel aufgearbeitet, ne? Also, weiß man nicht genau,
Linke und Grüne hatten sinnvolle Forderungen, sind aber äh wie gesagt relativ weit davon entfernt, da irgendetwas äh umsetzen zu können. Insofern können die da sowieso etwas andere Wahlprogramme schreiben als äh Parteien, bei denen irgendwie eine nennenswerte Einfluss.
In einer Regierungskoalition äh zumindest greifbar scheint,
So, was hat unsere, was hat unsere zukünftige Bundesregierung zu tun? Sie muss äh die ganze Snowden-Angelegenheit aufarbeiten.
Wird sie nicht tun.
Wird sie nicht tun. Ähm.
Datenschutzreform auf EU-Ebene.
Datenschutzreform auf EU-Ebene, ja. Wird man mal sehen, was da passiert? Themen wie Vorratsdatenspeicherung, Funk und Funkzellenabfrage, ja.
Da hätte man allenfalls unter Schwarz-Grün anstehen, dass ja entweder man.
Ja, also ich glaube nicht, dass selbst in schwarz-grün werden die Grünen es nicht hinkriegen, die Vorratsdatenspeicherung zu verhindern. Aber okay, also theoretisch unter Schwarz-Grün hätte man eine Option, dass eventuell die Fortseitenspeicherung nicht so problemlos einfach durchgewunken wird, wie es im Moment,
zu erwarten steht. Und man muss sich irgendwie mal langsam um den Export von Überwachungstechnologien Gedanken machen.
Stichwort äh Finn Fischer und andere äh Netzwerküberwachungs äh Software und Hardware, die irgendwie überall auf der Welt äh gegen die Freiheit der Menschen eingesetzt wird.
Wobei da ist wahrscheinlich politisch auch gegen die CDU durchaus noch was zu machen, beziehungsweise da sind auch bei der CDU sicherlich Leute äh mit Menschenrechts äh Fragen et cetera noch durchaus zu gewinnen, ne.
Ja, werden wir, werden wir sehen, ja. Also, dann steht halt zur Frage, warum sie letzten Jahre nichts getan haben. Aber okay, das Thema ist jetzt jetzt auf der Agen,
gehen wir mal von aus, ja, könnte durchaus ein Thema werden, wobei wir jetzt auch schon einer der letzten Sendungen gezeigt hatten. Gut, äh dann hängen die im Briefkasten in irgendeinem anderen Land auf und äh exportieren von dort, ja, also das äh.
Na gut, aber ich meine, irgendeiner muss ja anfangen. Es,
Ist halt einfach so, aber es wird sicherlich auch nicht das größte äh Problem. Ich meine, wird auch äh auch sehr jenseits der Netz äh Neutralität äh bin ich gespannt, ob äh was heißt,
bin überhaupt nicht gespannt. Rechne ich fest, damit das auch andere Dauerbrenner von
absolut überfälligen Grundsatzentscheidungen äh nicht kommen werden, ja, also sagen wir mal Korruptionsregelungen für Abgeordnete des Bundestages, ja, Deutschland ist eins der letzten Länder weltweit, was äh äh entsprechende äh
Korruptions ähm Einigung internationale Anti-Korruptionseinigung noch nicht in
Bundesgesetz äh übersetzt haben, war auch irgendwie überhaupt kein äh Thema, ja. Ist aber durchaus etwas, mit dem man Leute auch mal weiterhin unter Druck setzen kann,
Wollen wir denn.
Ja warte ganz kurz. In letzter Netzneutalität hast du schon gesagt, das wichtige Thema. Wie gesagt, interessiert die äh interessiert die CDU irgendwie nicht nennenswert. Es flattert da ja jetzt noch dieser komische Verordnungsentwurf von Rüssel rum. Ich hoffe mal, der verschwindet auch wieder in der Schublade
Ähm.
Telle könnte sich wiederum das könnte sich ganz wohltuend auswirken, dass.
Könnte man Hoffnung haben, denn die SPD hat sich der Netzneutralität verschrieben und die Grünen auch, ja, also da könnte man eventuell Hoffnung haben. Und das wäre natürlich gut, wenn man.
Die Linken auch.
So und dann haben wir noch.
Mehrheit des Bundestages spricht sich dafür aus.
Haben wir noch die die ganzen Fragenkomplex, was äh so Zugang angeht, also,
Haftung wäre so ein Thema, dessen sich die Bundesregierung mal annehmen könnte. Ähm Urheberrecht, ja, was ja eigentlich der der Auslöser für die ganzen Störerhaftungsgeschichten ist
Könnte irgendwie mal offene Daten und Transparenz angehen, ne? Also
IFG-Novelle äh Transparenzgesetz äh nach Hamburger äh Vorbildern irgendwie in den anderen Ländern oder auch auf Bundesebene einführen.
Also IFGF Informationsfreiheitsgesetz.
Informationsfreiheitsgesetz und ähm man könnte sich in Richtung des offenen Wissens äh äh bewegen. Ähm insbesondere bei Schulbüchern, aber, und das ist mir ehrlich gesagt viel wichtiger, dass ja so ein Thema, was mich die ganze Zeit,
immer noch so so aufrecht aus meiner Unizeit. Ähm wissenschaftliche Veröffentlichungen, ne.
Also das das Verlagswesen bei äh wissenschaftlichen Veröffentlichungen, das ist glaube ich so auch ein,
etwas, was man jetzt mal langsam ausmerzen müsste, aber auch da äh ist jetzt erstmal nicht viel zu erwarten. Diese Herausforderung äh, die ich da jetzt grade so zitiert habe, sind übrigens zusammengestellt vom äh Verein äh digitale Gesellschaft,
nicht nur dazu sagen. Das waren jetzt nicht so Sachen über die die ich mir so alle überlegt habe. Aber wenn man sich überlegt, was was das jetzt alles für Themenkomplexe sind und das mit mit der Mehrheitsverteilung und den Koalitionsoptionen, die wir jetzt ähm.
Grade im Bundestag mit dieser Sitzverteilung haben.
Ähm lässt auf eine spannende Zeit in der äh Netzpolitik.
Ein,
Sollten wir vielleicht noch kurz äh nachliefern. Als letzten Punkt zu dieser ganzen äh Wahldebatte, weil wir es komplett rausgelassen hat, es gab da ja auch mal dieses Piratenprojekt.
Ist nun erwartungsgemäß also zumindest was meine Erwartungen betrifft so aus dem Rennen gegangen wie ich's mir eben dachte.
Zwei Komma zwei Prozent, das ist nicht viel. Das ist äh geringfügig, mehr als mal bei der Europawahl eingesammelt haben.
Ähm,
worauf das zurückzuführen ist, denke ich mal, ist äh allen klar. Ja, also diese Selbstzerfleischung und diese Personal äh Querelen und diese Unmöglichkeit war zu irgendeinem Konset äh zu kommen, der über GO Anträge hinausgeht
hat einfach jegliches jeglichen Rückenwind, den sie gehabt haben und das war ja so wenig nicht, ja
komplett kompensiert. Also das interessant ist, dass sie nicht noch tiefer abgestürzt sind, also ich würde sagen, wären sie noch unter zwei Prozent äh gelandet, dann ähm hätten sie.
Wäre es ihnen sogar gelungen, noch ihre Hardcore-Unterstützerschaft auch noch äh vollständig zu verlieren, das scheint nicht passiert zu sein. Viele Leute haben sich gesagt, na ja,
Ich fand das zwar jetzt alles nicht so prickelnd, aber am Ende zählen für mich äh die Themen und wofür die Piraten stehen, auch wenn sie's vielleicht nicht.
Aktiv vertreten oder nur in Teilen vertreten, ja? Ich will das jetzt nicht so negativ rüberbringen, aber das ist, denke ich mal, die Wahrnehmung auch bei vielen Leuten, dass sie so gesagt haben, naja, also äh die Idee der Piraten an sich
ja? Äh diese Themenfelder der Zukunft, auch wenn sie heute noch so irre, weil irrelevant für viele irrelevant äh erscheinen mögen, ja. Äh das sind Themen, hinter denen ich äh äh kraft versammelt sehen möchte. Deswegen wähle ich Piraten
selbst wenn das äh Wahlsystem mich im Prinzip dafür bestraft.
Nun eingangs, ne? Diese Konstellation mit den fünfzehn Prozent, äh dass wenn man äh für kleine Parteien wählt, von denen so eine gefühlte Öffentlichkeit,
durch Umfragen und andere Erwartungshaltungen äh genährt wird, äh sagt.
Wird es nicht schaffen, diese fünf Prozent Hürde ist ja total tödlich, was äh die Unterstützung für solche Projekte äh betrifft. Da hatten wir ne, durch diese Berlinwahl haben die Piraten ja im Prinzip das gesprengt,
Deswegen hat's ja auch gleich dreimal geklappt bei den Landtagswahlen, weil alle gesagt haben, ah okay, das sind jetzt potenzielle Gewinner
Wenn ich da jetzt äh äh wähle, dann mache hat meine Stimme auch eine Auswirkung. Jetzt dürften sicherlich guten Prozent allein schon deshalb nicht äh
also dieses Prozent ist jetzt geraten, das basiert auf keinen Zahlen, aber so in der Größenordnung könnte es, halte ich's für durchaus realistisch. Die gesagt haben, naja, äh
Piraten fände ich ja irgendwie geil, wenn die jetzt bei sechs Prozent wären, ja, dann würde ich also in den Umfragen dann oder bei fünf oder vier Komma acht oder was auch immer, also irgendwas, was so das Gefühl gibt, könnte klappen, dann stimme ich da auch für
weil ansonsten, wenn ich das nicht mache und ich äh setze auf die Loser, dann habe ich meine äh Stimme verloren und das ist ja auch so, wie wir jetzt sehen in der in der Auszählung,
um äh der übrigbleibenden Großmachtkonstellation noch irgendeinen Ausflug äh einen Einfluss zu geben. Ne, also im Prinzip ist jetzt eine äh ich sag's jetzt mal ganz plump, so, wer jetzt für die Piraten gestimmt hat,
hat seine Stimme nicht genutzt um dem übrigbleibenden Konstrukt den richtigen Spin zu geben.
Ja, aber da kann's ja nicht dem, da kannst du jetzt nicht dem Wähler äh oder den Wählern, den.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, ich mache den Vorwurf dem Wahlsystem,
Ja, das, das ist halt genau das, äh worauf ich hinaus möchte. Das ist eigentlich mal Zeit wird auch die Diskussion darüber äh zu suchen. Ja, auch das wäre mal ein schönes Thema für die Piraten im Übrigen.
Ähm,
man nicht mal über eine Wahlreform nachdenken sollte, die eben so eine, so ein Mehrstimmwahlrecht äh macht, dass man aus der Zweitstimme quasi so eine,
was auch immer, so ein Fünferpack oder,
Also ich habe schon äh gab es schon einen Artikel auf dem Spiegel online, wo äh entsprechende Vorschauer gesagt haben, die extra Stimme, ja, so nach dem Motto, wenn meine erste Stimme äh äh versiegt, ja,
Dann habe ich noch eine zweite.
Das war der Hans Herbert von Anim.
Ja, kann sein, ihr habt mir den Namen leider nicht gemerkt. Ja, das ist schon mal der richtige Ansatz. Da kann ich halt nur zu sagen, ja, was ist für die zweite Extrastimme auch nicht äh gilt, was ist dann, ja?
Und und warum nicht generell sagen, die Zweitstimme ist quasi so eine Kreuz an, was du für richtig hältst, Stimme.
Weil hätte ich jetzt hingehen können und sagen können, okay, äh für mich ist jetzt äh CDU und FDP inakzeptabel, ja, aber so äh das linke äh Spektrum, meinetwegen einschließlich der Piraten,
äh ist schon okay. Ja, dann hätte ich quasi diesen Blog äh meine Unterstützung gegeben und das dann natürlich eine Aufgabe auch für äh Mathematiker und Wahlforscher äh da ein äh Auszählungssystem ähm,
dann dahinter zu stellen, was quasi diesen abgegebenen Stimmen auch äh die entsprechende äh ähm innewohnende Aussage dann äh ausrechnen lässt, natürlich,
Könnte man auch immer noch eine Fünf-Prozent- oder wie auch immer geartete äh Prozenthürde dort noch äh implementieren, aber man hätte halt die Möglichkeit zu sagen, äh,
vor allem, was man was man eigentlich nicht will, ja? So, ne? Also aus meiner Position, da beziehe ich jetzt mal ganz klar äh Position wird niemanden überraschen, ja. Also ich würde halt äh,
rechts ab CDU hat für mich einfach
keinerlei äh Wert in der aktuellen Konstellation und äh natürlich gibt's auch so im linken äh Spektrum
um äh einiges, was ich jetzt nicht unbedingt für wünschenswert äh gehalten äh hätte, ist auch nicht so sehr jetzt ein Links-Rechtsding, um es mal schnell klar zu machen
Also man kann halt einfach klar sagen, was man nicht will und dadurch äh zählt man automatisch auf, was man.
Ähm was man haben will, beziehungsweise wahltaktisch wäre es, wäre jetzt wahrscheinlich oder oder wie soll ich sagen,
um es verständlich zu machen, einer Masse müsste man natürlich für etwas wählen. Also,
rein wahl mathematisch ist es ja dasselbe, ob ich ankreuze, was ich nicht will äh oder ob ich ankreuze, was ich will, aber ich denke, es ist sehr viel einfacher äh es von den Leuten zu fordern, was für sie überhaupt noch in Frage kommt,
und daraus ein Wahlsystem machen und dann würden wir auch mit einer Konstellation in einem Parlament, die einfach, also die einerseits, wahrscheinlich ganz,
leicht veränderte, aber sehr viel realistischere Machtverhältnisse äh widerspiegelt, was die Leute wirklich wollen.
Zweitens würde auch dieses komische Koalitionsgeeier ein Ende haben, weil man nämlich im Prinzip aus diesen,
Abstimmung nicht nur Kräfteverhältnisse rechnen kann, sondern man kann auch die Zustimmungsraten für bestimmte Koalitionen,
direkt herausrechnen, ne, äh dieses, ja, der Wähler hat uns ja nicht gewählt dafür, dass wir mit den Linken zusammengehen, äh diese Aussage hätte dann einfach eine konkrete Zahl äh im Ergebnis äh wo man eben sieht, so,
Ja, doch. Ja, vielleicht doch. Wir sind nämlich so und so viel Prozent dafür und äh so und so viel Prozent sind dafür und könnte man sich diese Debatte auch sparen,
natürlich grundlegende Änderungen, vor denen natürlich alle wieder Angst haben und keine Ahnung, was sie äh da wieder ähm,
alles dagegen einzuwenden haben. Ich kann jetzt auch nicht sagen, dass ich diese These jetzt total durchdrungen habe. Würde mich übrigens sehr interessieren, falls ich Leute mit solchen Fragen schon auseinandergesetzt haben pro und contra hier in den Kommentaren dann noch was.
Drüber zu lesen.
Ja, also Wahlrechtsreform jetzt. So, wir sehen Wahl, wie jetzt ist, führt zu Ergebnissen, wie es jetzt ist, wollen wir nicht, wollen wir anders wählen.
Genau. Und auch die Frage der Opposition und äh Untersuchungsausschüsse, also der Kontrolle der Regierung. Also wir erleben jetzt eine Situation, in der einfach Regierungskontrolle nahezu unmöglich gemacht wird und das kann nicht gut sein.
So wollen wir weitermachen.
Ja, wir kommen, wir kommen zu dem Thema, auf das wichtige Zeit freue. Ich hatte recht.
Hat eine hat hatten wir uns da überhaupt bei Lokbuch Netzpolitik drüber unterhalten? Nein. Hatten wir uns drüber unterhalten?
Ja, selbstverständlich hatten wir uns darüber unterhalten, da hast du noch deine spannende Geschichte von der subkutanen Messung des Touch ID Sensors, der ganz besonders sicher ist von Apple und ähm.
Habe ich auch einen anderen Podcast gemacht und äh ich muss einsehen, äh ich hatte total Unrecht, ja. Apple hat gelogen, kann man nicht anders sagen.
Na ja, Apple hat nicht.
Doch, ich denke, sie haben gelogen, weil sie haben.
Bullshit gemacht, also was ich das Thema ist ja ganz, wir müssen ja kurz überhaupt erstmal reden, worum es geht. Äh erklären worum es geht. Der äh das iPhone fünf S kam raus und äh ich glaube es war ein Freitag, an dem das in den Handel geriet. Ähm.
Und am darauffolgenden Tag oder zwei Tage danach äh konnte dann der Chaos Computerclub ähm verkünden, dass äh Starbuck, der äh,
Junge Mann, der seit der sich so mit den Fingerabdrucksfälschereien seit längerer Zeit auseinandersetzt.
Schon seit ewigen Zeiten Biometrie, also seit äh ich weiß nicht, seit neunundneunzig äh ist er irgendwie dabei oder länger noch.
Neunundneunzig oder so, dass es ihm äh sofort gelungen ist, ohne äh Probleme ähm diesen Sensor zu umgehen. Ähm Starbuck hat.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, er hat nicht den Sinn, er ist hat nicht den Sensor.
Fängst du auch schon an. Kann ich das vielleicht kurz erzählen?
Meine Güte, bevor also jetzt ich erkläre das jetzt, ich werde diese Debatte jetzt echt ein für alle mal beenden. So, was macht Starbuck? Er macht genau das, was ich vorhergesagt habe. Das hat, das ist nichts Überraschendes, weil ich Starbucks ja auch kenne. Der hat äh hat ein iPhone genommen,
hat das auf einen äh Scanner gelegt, hat äh den Fingerabdruck, der sich auf dem iPhone befand mit diesem Scanner abgenommen, hat ihn in Photoshop ein bisschen verstärkt und äh,
ähm dann äh auf also ein bisschen bearbeitet, bisschen verstärkt, umgedreht natürlich, weil der Fingerabdruck ja auf dem iPhone spiegelverkehrt ist, ähm invetiert und dann ähm auf äh Transparentpapier gedruckt.
Dieses Transparenzpapier auf eine ähm Platine gelegt, die ähm.
Ja wie nennt man das, ist ein PCB, also eine eine Platine, die man belichtet und dann,
also was halt jeder Elektrobastler macht, wenn er sich eine Platine baut, äh man man legt quasi
Ausdruck von dem Schaltkreis, den man mit dieser Platine äh widerspiegeln möchte auf diese Platine, belichtet das Ganze irgendwie ein paar äh dreißig Sekunden oder so mit UV-Licht
und legt's dann in eine oder nee, dreißig Sekunden ein bisschen länger. Also man legt's dann in eine in eine Wanne und ätzt das Metall weg, was man nicht haben möchte und das Metall, was man haben möchte, bleibt stehen
und dadurch hat man dann ähm entweder eine eine schöne ähm.
Einen schönen Schaltkreis, wie meinen, wie man ihn dann eben belöten möchte oder man hat eine,
ähm in diesem Fall eine Schablone für einen Fingerabdruck. Da hat er dann Graphit draufgesprüht und ein bisschen Holzleim reingepumpt,
mit der also Holzleim drüber gezogen, gewartet bis das Ganze getrocknet ist. Diese Fingerabdruckkopie abgezogen und diesen Holzleimgraphit gemischten Fingerabdruck ähm erfolgreich genutzt, um das iPhone ähm,
zu entsperren, dass diesen Finger gelernt hatte.
Und jetzt gibt's äh das heißt, er hat genau das naheliegendste und das äh wahrscheinlichste und auch gefährlichste Angriffsszenario, was dieser Fingerabdrucksensor birgt,
ähm,
durchgespielt und gezeigt, dass es funktioniert. Nämlich das, wovor alle immer waren, dass man diesen biometrischen Fingerabdruck, äh der jetzt da zum Entschließen des Telefons ähm.
Genutzt wird, überall hinterlässt, unter anderem auf der Oberfläche des iPhones selber, auf jedem Glas Wasser, aus dem man trinkt
bei jeder US-Einreise, wo man seine Finger auf den grünen Sensor seine komplette Hand, alle Finger und den Daumen auf diesen Sensorlicht überall hinterlässt man
genau dieses eine Merkmal und kann es nicht mehr loswerden,
Und dieses eine Merkmal kann man auf diesen mittels dieses Verfahrens innerhalb sehr kurzer Zeit mit Baumarkt äh Zubehör,
fälschen und somit Zugriff auf das iPhone bekommen und sich zum Kauf im Apple Store authentifizieren.
Wenn das der User entsprechend freigeschaltet hat.
So und jetzt wird das Geschrei laut. Ja, also abgesehen davon, dass Starbuck damit äh,
äh einen von der Hacker-Community Internationalen Hacker-Community ausgelobten,
Wettbewerb gewonnen hat, der darin mündete das jetzt relativ viele äh relativ hohe Geldspenden an die Raumfahrtagentur in Berlin gehen.
Ähm wurde gab es dann, gab es denn Schlaumeier und ich höre jetzt raus, dass du dazugehörst, die sagen, der Sensor wurde nicht gehackt.
Das habe ich nicht gesagt. Der Sensor wurde gehackt, aber äh äh er wurde nicht umgangen.
Ah okay, ja gut, äh okay, das ist das ist richtig. Er wurde.
Natürlich wurde der gehackt und wieder gehackt wurde. Ich meine äh da dieser Artikel fand ja auch sehr interessant. Die kamen so irgendwie vor allem aus diesem US äh äh Mekkentosh äh Fanboy äh Ecke. Ja, äh wo ich auch so ein bisschen gegrübbelt habe, wovon die jetzt eigentlich reden. Da
man aber auch wieder, äh dass es sehr unterschiedliche Vorstellungen darüber gibt, was Hack jetzt so ist, ja, also ähm.
Ja, aber das da bin ich halt die diese unterschiedliche Vorstellung von was ein Hack ist, wurde hauptsächlich von Leuten vertreten, die bisher nicht als Hacker aufgefallen sind. Und ähm.
Ist folgendes zu sagen, also natürlich wurde dann gesagt, ja ein wirklicher Hack ist es, wenn ähm,
oder ein ein weiterer Hack würde ich jetzt sagen, ist es, wenn man jetzt zum Beispiel diese äh die Sicherheitsfunktion über das TPM und so wie der äh Fingerabdruck im Telefon gespeichert wird,
umgeht, wenn man den Sensor tatsächlich umgeht, sagen wir mal, durch einen Hardwareangriff, also zum Beispiel das äh Protokoll ähm.
Reimplementiert, wie dieser Sensor mit dem iPhone spricht. Irgendwie sagt der Sensor dem iPhone, ja, hier ist alles in Ordnung,
dass man diesen Teil irgendwie, was weiß ich.
Probt auf dem auf der Wortverbindung und dann den Sensor einfach ablötet und dem iPhone immer sagt, ja ja, hier ist alles in Ordnung. Ähnliche Sachen, also dachten dann eher im im Hardware beziehungsweise im Bereich an einen Hack ähm,
Was sicherlich auch interessant ist, was sicherlich auch noch Personen versuchen werden,
der entscheidende Punkt ist aber bei einem Hack, dass selten ein Hacker sich einen größeren Aufwand macht, als er eigentlich muss. Und wenn ich das iPhone nun mal für meinen Angriff noch nicht mal öffnen muss, weil der.
Schlüssel ja draufklebt.
Oben auf dem Glas, auf der Oberfläche.
Weil der Schlüssel oben auf dem Glas klebt, dann ähm,
ist es äh sage ich mal, sind die anderen Angriffsszenarien, die da jetzt benannt wurden, dann eher im Bereich der äh ja, der sicher, der wirklichen Sicherheitsforschung ähm aber nicht im Bereich der äh praktikabel zur Anwendung gebrachten,
werdenden Hacks. Aber ich bin mir relativ sicher, dass auch der Rest da noch äh unter die Lupe genommen wird.
Ähm warum das Ganze überhaupt ein Thema der äh der Netzpolitik ist, also ähm oder warum ich das hier in in diesem Podcast besprechen wollte. Ähm.
Das mal verdeutlicht wird, was dieses gesamte Thema der Biometrie eigentlich bedeutet. Also aufgrund,
dessen, also im Security-Bereich. Als einzelnes Merkmal ist ähm Biometrie,
einfach ungeeignet zu einer äh Authentifizierung. Also wenn ich's dieser Fall jetzt ich entschlüsse, ich entlocke meinen Computer mittels meines Fingerabdrucks. Die Dinger sind ja auch schon seit jeher in den Finger drin. Das sind die Geräte, an denen äh Starbuck,
anfangs auch geübt hat, ja, die er auch alle umgeht. Ähm.
Problem wie gesagt ist, ich ich habe dieses Merkmal nur einmal, ich ich kann es verlieren und selbst wenn ich es irgendwie versuche zu schützen.
Wie jetzt beispielsweise eine Iris oder sowas, ja, wenn man dann oder oder das Netzhautbild, wenn man dann so einen Netzhautscanner wie beim Militär hat oder so,
Das äh Problem ist, dass ich dieses Merkmal nicht ändern kann, wenn ich's einmal, wenn es mir einmal kompromittiert wurde,
und daraus entstehen eben Probleme, die zu meinem Nachteil sind als Nutzer der Mädels dieses Merkmales etwas schützen möchte.
Wenn man es aber umdreht und sagt ich möchte die Biometrie nicht nutzen für den Fall, dass ähm.
Dass ich dass jemand einen Anreiz hat sich als ich auszugeben,
sondern für den Fall, dass jemand anderes nicht den Anreiz hat, sich als mich auszugeben, sondern allenfalls ich einen Anreiz habe, mich selbst nicht für mich auszugeben. Okay.
Kann ihnen nicht folgen.
Okay, es kommt auf den Prüfzweck an. Da ist ein Fingerabdrucksensor.
Ich muss meinen Finger dadrauf halten, ja? Und jetzt der der der Unterschied im Prüfzweck ist, will ich das sein, was der Fingerabdrucksensor erwartet oder will ich es nicht sein?
Im iPhone ist der Fall, ich will es sein, weil er verhindert mir den Zugang zu etwas, ja? Das heißt, ich möchte ich sein und jemand anderes, der Zugang zu meinem Gerät haben möchte, möchte auch ich sein.
In diesem Fall ist der Finger, ist, sind biometrische Merkmale ungeeignet, weil der Angreifer,
eben immer in der Lage sein wird, mit in diesem Fall mäßigen, in anderen Fällen vielleicht etwas größerem Aufwand, dieses biometrische Merkmal zu fälschen.
Umgekehrter Fall. Ich stehe vor diesem Sensor und ich will nicht ich sein. Das heißt, dieser Sensor, wenn er mich identifiziert, hat negative Konsequenzen für mich. Beispielsweise ähm Überwachung,
US-Einreise, ja? Da hätte ich natürlich ein großes Interesse diesen Sensor äh irgendwie auszutricksen und andere Finger drauf zu legen. Deswegen steht da auch ein Einreise äh Behörde Furz, die daneben und guckt, dass ich genau das nicht tue.
Das heißt, im Überwachungsfall, wo die Identifikation durch diesen Sensor zu meinem Nachteil ist.
In diesem Fall sind biometrische Merkmale sehr gut geeignet, weil ich sie nämlich nicht loswerden kann. Im Gegensatz zu.
Also im Sinne des äh Angreifers an der Stelle, also im Falle des Überwachenden, aber für äh das das genau, das.
Genau, weil es kein Angriffsszenario, es gibt kein Angriffsszenario mehr, dass sich jemand fälschlicherweise als ich ausgeben möchte, wenn ich einmal auf der, auf der Liste der der äh verfolgten äh Gedankenverbrecher bin,
Das heißt, in dem Fall,
kann das Gerät mit seiner Sicherheit sehr, sehr gut mich von anderen unterscheiden und sagen, das ist der Neumann, ja? Und deswegen kennen wir Fingerabdrücke auch seit,
weiß ich nicht wie langer Zeit aus der aus der äh Strafverfolgung und erst seit relativ kurzer Zeit in der äh in der IT-Sicherheit.
Weil sie eben aufgrund dessen, dass man sie nicht loswerden kann, sehr viel besser äh zur Überwachung und Kontrolle geeignet sind als zu einer tatsächlichen Authentifikation. Ersetze Fingerabdrücke an dieser Stelle durch jedes andere biometrische Merkmal.
Dass was Apple jetzt das andere Argument, was was viele äh Apologeten äh anbringen, ist ja, Touch ID ist ähm.
Also der Fingerabdrucksensor am iPhone ist für die Sicherheit gut, äh für die für die Bequemlichkeit gedacht und.
Für die meisten Nutzer führt er zu einem Anstieg der Sicherheit, denn die meisten Nutzer haben noch nicht einmal einen vierstelligen Code an ihrem Telefon.
Und das Argument, da gehe ich ja sogar noch mit,
also eine unsichere Sicherheitsmaßnahme oder einen nicht besonders sicheren Sicherheitsmaßnahme ist immer noch besser, als eine ähm,
nicht vorhandene Sicherheitsmaßnahme. Also diese Scherze wie, was weiß ich, Person ist auf Toilette. Ähm man kann irgendwie, man twittert mal schnell was. Ähm solche.
Bierlaune, Angriffe äh verhindert hat, ID ähm auf eine sehr komfortable Weise und spart den Menschen in vielen Fällen den Ärger beim Anlocken ihres iPhones den Finger da drauf zu halten.
Dann kann ich's aber nicht so bewerben, wie Apple das jetzt getan hat, als äh besonders hohes, robustes Sicherheitsfeature.
Ja, vor allem, was äh, wo ich mir jetzt nicht ganz sicher bin, ob das nicht zwischen den Zeilen irgendwie erwähnt hast, ähm, wenn man halt.
Quasi in einer Bedrohungssituation ist, ja, sagen wir mal, jemand will,
Das Telefon klauen und dann davon auch noch einen Nutzen haben et cetera, ne. Dann äh,
kann man ja auch leicht dazu gezwungen werden, diese diesen Fingerabdruck zu liefern. Also wenn mich drei Leute festhalten.
Und mein Finger auf dieses Telefon drauf drücken, so dann habe ich halt keine Chance. Ja, während der Aufwand mir eine Zahlenkombination zu entlocken, nochmal auf einem anderen Level,
Also,
Ja, ist äh schwierig. Ich denke, dass jetzt, sagen wir mal, die konkrete Implementierung in diesem Telefon, also und, und, und dem Schutzbereich, um den es jetzt hier geht, mit der Ausnahme des Kaufens und dem damit verbundenen finanziellen äh Schwierigkeiten,
noch nicht unbedingt ähm,
das Ende der Welt äh herbeiruft so. Äh ich denke, der Club hat es jetzt auch mal primär auch erstmal aus sportlichen Erwägungen natürlich gemacht, ne.
Es war ein Hackerwettbewerb und es war klar, dass Starbuck den gewinnen musste. Der Mann, der war völlig nervös und hatte vor,
Was meinst du, was der für für äh Bäume äh versucht hat zu versetzen, um an dieses dämliche Telefon zu kommen?
Ja, ähm es war klar, ab dem Moment, wo die Dinger verkauft werden, läuft die Zeit. Der Mann hatte einen Ruf zu verteidigen und hatte natürlich auch äh Muffe, dass ähm,
dass Apple da irgendwas jetzt wirklich gut gemacht hat mit der äh Offentech Bude, die sie sich da gekauft haben, ja? Die die Befürchtung stand durchaus im Raume. Und es gibt ähm,
Vielleicht noch kurz weiter zur Biometrie, in der äh in der CCC Veröffentlichung war dann noch die Rede davon, dass ähm das Verfahren ähm,
quasi genauer gemacht werden musste als vor als vor vielen Jahren als Tabak das zum ersten Mal gemacht hat. Ähm.
Ben und Dexter, die so, sage ich mal, die äh wie soll man das sagen, die.
Als Mentor hatten und auch diese Biometrieforschung machen,
haben sich dann äh einen Tag später in Ruhe hingesetzt und haben den Fingerabdruck nicht mit einem äh hoch Qualitätsscanner abgenommen, wie Starbucks das von vornherein gemacht hat, weil der natürlich fürchtete,
dieser Sensor, den er sich jetzt gegenüber befindet, ähm komplexer ist und schwieriger auszu äh tricksen ist
Benno Dexter haben's einen Tag später mitm iPhone gemacht. Das heißt, sie haben ein iPhone so drangehalten, dass der LED-Blitz in iPhone vier S sogar,
besondere Detail. IPhone vier S, den Fingerabdruck einfach abfotografiert,
und haben damit auch ein äh Funktionen funktionierenden Klon herstellen können. Das heißt, diese zweieinhalbtausend DPI-Auflösungen mit der Starbucks sich dem Problem gelöst äh genähert hat, war äh noch nicht mal ausschlaggebend dafür, dass das Verfahren erfolgreich war.
Na, aus welcher Nähe hat denn das äh vier S diesen äh aufgenommen, weil.
Sehr nah, so nah wie's ging und deswegen war es auch ein 4S, weil das 4S noch näher äh makrofokussiert, als das fünf S. Und deswegen wird das Foto oder aus irgendwelchen Gründen sich das besser, besser ging.
Na gut, aber wenn du da nah rangehst, dann bist du ja auch äh sehr sehr nah an zweitausendvierhundert DPI. Also ich meine zweitausendvierhundert Punkte pro zwei Komma fünf Zentimeter.
Ja, ich weiß nicht genau, ob.
Wenn sie da, wenn sie dann nur zweieinhalb Zentimeter entfernt waren, dann ist das dieselbe Auflösung.
Ja, ich glaube, so nah kannst du es nicht dran halten. Das ist schon etwas größerer Abstand. Also so nahe kommst du nicht.
Gut, weiß ich nicht, aber äh ja, das wäre nochmal interessant zu sehen ähm zu schauen, aber ich äh ja, warum ich.
Kann ich dir, kann ich dir, kann ich dir sagen, welche Auflösung das denn war. Aber äh ich ich guck's jetzt nicht raus.
Das Entscheidende war und das fand ich den fand ich den entsprechenden Satz, den den ich da, den ich irgendwo hörte, es sieht so aus, als hätte der CCC Touch ID schon vor neun Jahren gehackt,
sie mussten nur noch warten, dass sie das iPhone bekommen. Und das war glaube ich der,
äh der Punkt hier. Aber äh ja, wie wie du gerade schon sagtest, so für den, für den normalen Nutzer, ist dieses Sicherheitsfeature im Vergleich zum äh zu einem ungesicherten iPhone ähm.
Sicherlich Gewinn bringend und auch im Vergleich zu dem Risiko, dass was weiß ich, dein Partner oder bester Freund,
oder eben äh nah enger Feind, äh dir mal über die Finger äh über die Schulter geschaut hat bei deinem beim Eingeben deines vier äh vier äh.
Codes, ähm weil du nicht den längeren benutzt ähm in im Rahmen dieser Angriffsszenarien ist das Telefon ähm besser geschützt.
Ähm durch den Fingerabdruck als durch durch diesen,
nur Sicherheitsforschung bewegt sich eben nicht in in diesem Rahmen liebe Freunde, sondern sie bewegt sich eben im Rahmen dessen, dass jemand eine Behauptung aufstellt und ein,
System als besonders sicher bezeichnet was es nach,
einfachen äh kritischen Betrachtungen sich als als sehr übertrieben,
behauptet, äh herausstellt. Und das Problem wie gesagt ist, damit möchte ich eigentlich schließen, dass dieses iPhone unter Umständen.
Dazu führt, dass Menschen sich an biometrische Erfassung gewöhnen.
Für akzeptabel halten. Ich hoffe jedoch, dass Menschen viel mehr diese biometrische Erfassung deswegen, da sie jetzt sehen, wie leicht äh solche Merkmale gefälscht werden können, eben dann ablehnen werden.
Das wäre mein äh mein Wunsch, ähm auch wenn man die Möglichkeit äh nur bedingt hat und sie zum Beispiel bei der Einreise in die USA eben auch mit dem Kauf eines äh Rückflugtickets einhergeht.
Gut, ähm denke, dabei können wir es jetzt auch erstmal äh belassen. Ich teile die
uneingeschränkte äh Angst jetzt mit irgendwie, dass das jetzt so die die die Einführung der äh Biometrie an sich äh durch die Hintertür ist, nicht so ohne Weiteres, aber ich denke, es war ein sehr angemessenes äh Exempel, was man hier mal
statuieren musste und auch war es auch absolut erforderlich da dem dem Hype von Apple etwas entgegenzusetzen weil
Mitnichten ist es so, dass sie dort ein eine neue Art der Fingerabdruckerkennung gemacht haben, ja? Sie haben im Prinzip ja den Eindruck, äh,
erzeugen wollen, dass sie da wirklich eine richtige Fingererkennung haben, ne, indem sie quasi in die tiefen Schichten blicken und nicht auf den Abdruck, ja,
und äh das ist einfach mal nicht so, ja. Das ist äh ich frage mich ehrlich gesagt, was eigentlich wirklich neu ist. Ja, also was
ist es wirklich nur so, dass der Sonser besonders klein äh äh ist und sich halt eben auch noch mit so einem Drucksensor äh so ein Druck äh Knopf kombinieren lässt, das ist dann eben für ihre konkrete äh Einsatzort, war das eben optimal, aber ansonsten ist da technisch nichts Neues.
Aus technischer Hinsicht würde man denen vor allem, also ich gehe mal davon aus, Apple wollte ja.
Ich meine, was bringt denen am Ende größere Nutzerunzufriedenheit,
irgendwie einer sagt, ich habe das Ding überlistet und ähm dann die äh die Fanpresse schreibt, äh das ist kein Hack, weil wir jetzt neuerdings sagen, was ein Hack ist,
oder wenn sie jetzt das Ding so gebaut hätten, dass der wirklich gut prüft,
häufiger zu einem falschen Negativ führt. Das heißt, dass die Menschen da ihren Finger drauf halten, dann geht der nicht. Dann ist Winter, dann kriegst du dein Telefon auf einmal nicht anlockt. Das meinst du, wenn das Internet auf einmal voll steht mit ist ein Mist,
ich komme nicht an mein Telefon dran, weil ich habe mir den Finger geschnitten, ja? Ähm.
Im im übertragenen Sinne jetzt. Ich weiß ja, dass das so das Ding fragt dann im Zweifelsfall einfach am Ende nach dem Code und dann ist gut. Aber ähm.
Es ist so, dass die, dass die Audienz, mit der sie da zu tun haben, natürlich, glaube ich, ganz äh auch wirklich Wert eher auf die Bequemlichkeit legt, als auf die auf die Sicherheit dieses Merkmal.
Genau und ich denke, man man muss vielleicht Touch-ID auch eher im Bereich Convenience Feature äh einsortieren als äh Security Feature.
Richtig, hätte man aber dann eben auch als Feature äh bewerben und verkaufen müssen.
Und dass sie das nicht getan haben, das prallen wir an.
So, äh was prangern wir denn noch an? Wir prangern doch immer so viel. Ja.
Wir prangern noch was an. Das ist etwas, was ich meine vor Anfang des Jahres, weil das Thema, da hatten wir es auch kurz äh besprochen,
Und zwar ähm.
Geht es um die Frage, der sich die Bundesnetzagentur jetzt, die sich die sich die Bundesnetzagentur stellt, wo ist quasi ähm das, dass ein Internet.
Zu Ende und wo fängt quasi der Hoheitsbereich des Nutzers an? Ähm.
Wir wissen ja zu Unsinn, also wenn wir uns einen Internetanschluss geben lassen,
liegt da erstmal an der Telefondose nicht Internet an, sondern da liegt ähm DSL an. Und äh wer wer irgendwie
Zu den frühen Nutzern von DSL gehörte, der weiß, dass äh man dann erstmal da einen Splitter dran gesteckt hat, der hat dann das ISDN und das äh DSL voneinander getrennt. Auf der einen Dose war dann eben ISDN. Auf der anderen Dose war DSL.
Dahinter kam dann das Modem, das hat den äh Einwahlprozess gemacht,
und dann eine Internetverbindung hergestellt und in der Regel hatte man dahinter dann nochmal einen Router stecken,
Das waren in den in den Anfangszeiten von DSL so drei Geräte, die man sich dann da irgendwie äh an die Wand äh genagelt hat,
um am Ende ähm irgendwie ein genattetes IP-Netz zu Hause zu haben. Und irgendwo und dieses Alpine Netz war ja dann sehr klar ein lokales Netz. Das heißt, irgendwo auf dem Weg dazwischen wurde aus Internet,
äh dann äh Linus Wohnzimmer, wo Internet drangesteckt wird. Und.
Die lernläufige Meinung war eigentlich, dass es nach dem Splitter war. Ja, also das da ist dann jetzt.
Da ist dann jetzt irgendwie DSL und da spreche ich irgendwie PPOE darüber und dann habe ich Internet. Man könnte aber natürlich auch argumentieren, naja, solange du nicht äh dich wirklich dann die Verbindung zum Internet hergestellt hast und eine,
IP-Adresse hast in diesem Internet, hast du auch noch kein wirkliches Internet, also ist wirkliches Internet erst nach dem Mode. Und ähm.
Heutzutage sind alle diese drei Geräte in einem verbunden, nämlich zum Beispiel in der Fritzbox. Und.
Die Frage, die sich jetzt stellt, ist muss mein Anbieter, wenn er mir zum Beispiel eine.
Fritzbox liefert oder äh eine modifizierte Fritzbox, äh wo dann draufsteht, wie heißen die Dinger bei bei der Telekom.
Oder was nee.
Die Zeiten sind vorbei. Ähm Gott, wie heißen die, Scheißteile. Egal, kommen wir ja noch.
Ja, also Telekom-Ding oder äh Easy-Box, Aqua-Easy-Box draufsteht und in diesem Ding dann eben gespeichert sind, die Zugangsdaten, die das Gerät beim beim Herstellen der PPP OE Verbindung verwendet, also meine,
DSL Internetzugangsdaten,
Die sind in dem Gerät gespeichert und die sind eigentlich ein Geheimnis, dass der Anbieter und ich teilen,
Und ich glaube, es war der Anbieter Alice, der als allererstes angefangen hat, den Leuten WLAN-Router zu geben, die dann irgendwie nur ein oder zwei Clients zugelassen haben und gesagt hat, na ja,
keinen Bock darauf, dass du äh das irgendwie mit mehr Leuten teilst, die sollen sich dann auch einen Alice Anschluss holen. Und aus diesem Grunde verraten wir dir nicht die Zugangsdaten.
Damit du nicht unseren beschränkten Router,
ersetzt durch einen potenteren Router, der dann äh äh für mehr Menschen äh Internet schafft als wir vorsehen.
Mhm.
Und ähm.
Der die Debatte ist, also jetzt, wie ich schon grade anfangs sagte, ist dieser Router ein Endgerät oder ist ein Netzbestandteil?
Denn nur wenn er ein Netzbestandteil ist, kann der Provider argumentieren, deshalb gebe ich dir nicht die Zugangsdaten, weil das ist ein Teil, das zu unserem Netz gehört, damit hast du nix äh zu schaffen.
Und ähm wenn er aber sagt, das ist ein Endgerät, dann kann der Nutzer sagen, ich möchte gerne einen anderen Router benutzen, lieber Provider, sag doch mal, wie ich meinen anderen Router, den ich hier stehen habe, äh konfigurieren muss,
Damit ich äh ans Internet kann. Und es ist natürlich klar, dass die äh.
Verbraucherfreundliche Variante ist zu sagen, ja Splitter oder THE-Dose ungefähr da, ist der Netzabschlusspunkt und alles, was dahinter kommt, ist äh Endgerät.
Und diese Meinung hat die äh Bundesnetzagentur in einer ersten Entscheidung jetzt erstmal nicht so geteilt.
Anfang des Jahres. Und.
Also sie hat die Meinung entgeräts nicht geteilt, sondern es als Netzbestandteil gesehen.
Genau, sie hat gesagt, es ist in Ordnung. Der Nutzer kann den Netzanbieter nicht dazu zwingen, die Zugangsdaten herauszugeben, beziehungsweise der Netzanbieter hat das Recht, diese Zugangsdaten nicht,
herauszugeben. Und damit quasi den den Nutzern.
Zur Verwendung eines bestimmten Beruhters zu zwingen und das macht der Anbieter natürlich nur aus dem Interesse diesen Router dann in seinen Funktionen irgendwie manipulieren zu können.
Ja, also äh was, glaube ich, in dieser Debatte mal Nottäte und ich weiß nicht, inwiefern das jetzt in dieser Debatte bisher schon äh,
Vielleicht getan wurde, zumindest von manchen Seiten, ist diese äh Funktionsbereiche innerhalb diesen Geräten äh innerhalb dieser Geräte besser zu unterscheiden, weil wir hast ja schon eingangs erwähnt heutzutage, also wenn du so eine Fritzbox kaufst, ja, im Prinzip alles machen kann, ja?
Dann kommen ja da verschiedene ähm Funktionalitäten äh zusammen, ja? Das äh Funktionalität eins ist halt das DSL Modem, also quasi die physikalische Dekodierung des eigentlichen Signals, ja,
wo ich sagen würde, okay, das äh kann man sehr wohl auch als Netzbestandteil sehen, weil es eigentlich
Viele gute Gründe gibt, warum ein Provider diesen Teil nicht in gewisser Hinsicht zumindest unter Teilkontrolle haben sollte
um einfach eine Verbesserung der Übertragung sicherzustellen, Störungen zu vermeiden et cetera. Wir wissen auch, dass häufig in Systemen, das kennt man auch aus WLAN und so weiter, also überall, wo du quasi über eine äh mitspielende Gegenseite keine Kontrolle hast
hast du das Problem, dass du eben schnell in Störersituationen kommen kannst, die dann mehr als nur für den eigenen Bedarf da zu Problemen führten.
Ist einfach so. Die zweite Komponente, die man trennen muss, ist die eigentliche
der eigentliche, äh wie soll ich sagen, der eigentliche Berechtigungszugang, ja, wo
interessanterweise ja heutzutage immer noch äh Passwörter, zumindest bei manchen Providern verwendet werden, ja, um so einen Einwahlvorgang durchzuführen, der ja eigentlich absurd ist,
Also eigentlich muss man sich halt sehr fragen, warum muss ich mich eigentlich noch einwählen,
Ich sitze hier zu Hause. Mein Telefon hat sich ja zu Hause auch nicht eingewählt. Warum soll mein Interneteinschluss sich einwählen?
Ist ja nicht so, dass ich über eine öffentliche Vermittlungsstelle äh anwähle, sondern ich habe ja hier einen definierten Endpunkt. Ich habe ja hier einen,
ein Kabel. Das kann man da argumentieren. Na ja, bla, bla, bla, sicherheitszugang. Was ist, wenn dir einer ein Kabel im Keller äh abklemmt und so weiter, das äh schützt dich ja auch vor Missbrauch,
meinetwegen, aber an der Stelle schon zu sagen, dass es jetzt auch immer noch die Kontrolle des Netzes, da wird's schon schwierig, weil es ja eigentlich auch schon von seiner Funktion her den äh Ort definiert, wo der User zum Nutzer, äh zum Dienst kommt.
Und äh die dritte Komponente, die nämlich dann quasi aus dem
erlangt Netzzugang mir ein Heimnetz bereitstellt
Alle Raute heutzutage haben in der Regel WLAN mit drin, machen halt so Sachen wie äh Verteilung, IPV sechs Zugänge et cetera, äh VPN Funktionalität und so weiter und so fort.
Das sind natürlich Dinge, die eigentlich sehr viel was auch mit meinem Heimnetz zu tun haben und an der Stelle äh äh würde ich dann auch mal in so einer Debatte, die äh dieses Grundrecht, dessen vollständigen Namen niemand jederzeit äh auf der Zunge hat, ob vielleicht mit der Ausnahme von äh Markus,
und Frank Liga äh weiß schon das Grundrecht auf die Unverletzlichkeit der eigenen IT-Systeme
was sich im Rahmen der Entscheidung des Bundesverfassungsgerichts zur Onlinedurchsuchung seiner Zeit mal ergeben hat,
Ähm ob das nicht an der Stelle dann auch schon verletzt wird, weil äh wieso darf eine Telekom.
Quasi auch den Zugang zu einem WLAN bestimmen und damit äh dritten äh die Mitnutzung meines Anschlusses äh,
erlauben, ja? Klar, da kannst du argumentiert, das ist ja irgendwie alles isoliert und lalala. Aber äh ob sie dann auch wirklich die Sicherheit, also die Undurchbrechbarkeit äh zu meinem WLAN,
äh also zu meinem Heimnetz quasi beim lokalen Lahn auch wirklich äh in allen Fällen äh problemlos sicherstellen kann, dass äh ist mal eine ganz andere Frage, ne.
Ja, also damit hat das dann wirklich nix zu tun.
Also die diese drei Komponenten sollte man da glaube ich auch mal klar äh benennen, ja. Wie gesagt, Level eins, da lasse ich mit mir reden. Auch wenn man äh durch die Nutzung einer Fritzbox und des DSL-Modims heutzutage auch immer noch,
interessante äh Fakten äh,
hervorzaubern kann, ja? Also es ist zum Beispiel mit der Fritzbox problemlos möglich, äh dem Probader nachzuweisen, dass man sehr wohl hier mehr als nur die tatsächlich geschalteten drei Megabit oder sowas bekommen könnte, weil mir sagt das Gerät, dass es genau eben eine andere Geschwindigkeit real durchgetestet hat
Äh das ist ihnen natürlich auch ein wenig ein Dorn im Auge.
Na ja, es geht denen halt vor allem, wie gesagt, also diese technische Definition ist ja jetzt erstmal nur ein ein erster Schritt.
Nämlich am Ende dazu führt.
Dass sie dich zur Nutzung eines bestimmten Endgerätes zwingen. Also es ist eine es ist eine einerseits eine technische Frage. Es ist aber in ihrer in ihrer.
Äh in dem Resultat, dass ihre Beantwortung herbeiführt, eine ähm.
Ja, eine Frage des äh Verbraucherschutzes im Prinzip, ja? Äh.
Beziehungsweise vielleicht sogar eine noch viel größere wie du gerade schon andeutetest mit dem mit dem Grundrecht auf äh Unverletzlichkeit der äh informationstechnischen Systeme. Ähm,
Das Ergebnis wird eventuell sein, dass wir äh nicht mehr andere Geräte nutzen dürfen. Fertig. Und damit haben sich so viele Dornen im Auge äh der.
Der Netzprovider.
Entfernt, ja? Oder lassen sich dann entfernen, dass das ein ein sehr wichtiger Kampf ist, der da mit noch nicht ausreichender ähm.
Öffentlicher Aufmerksamkeit geführt ist, weil es mal wieder etwas ist, wo keine
wo keine nennenswerte Mehrheit äh die technischen Gegebenheiten versteht. Und deswegen denke ich, der ähm der Begriff Routerzwang ist da der entscheidende. Also roter Zwang, lassen wir uns zwingen,
Router zu verwenden oder haben wir die freie Wahl. Auch hier ist wieder das Problem, dass der größere Teil der äh der Bürger sagt, ich bin noch nicht bescheuert und kaufe mir noch einen anderen Router.
Also wir sehen mal wieder eine ein Themenbereich, der schwer zu vermitteln ist, der unter Umständen sehr schöne Konsequenzen hat.
Und der jetzt gerade diskutiert wird, das ist das Entscheidende bis zum sechsten November, kann man da ähm ähm quasi den Bundesnetzagentur ähm.
Die Meinung.
Ellungnahmen äh zukommen lassen. Die ähm.
Software Foundation Europe hat das schon gemacht, deren deren Ansicht ist natürlich klar, ähm.
Aber auch, äh, wenn ich das richtig sehe, gibt's da keinerlei Beschränkungen, wer das darf und äh, wer nicht.
Und das wäre jetzt mal ganz interessant ähm wie gesagt
im Juni haben sie angekündigt, das zu vertiefen. Da haben sie dann irgendwie mit einigen schon gesprochen und äh eine Stellungnahme kann man da bis zum November einkommen lassen, ankommen lassen. Und dann wird's natürlich, bin ich mal gespannt, was die äh was dann da am Ende rauskommt bei der Bundesnetzagentur,
dass sie da sich mal darauf besinnen, dass sie Netzagentur sind und nicht äh,
Agentur.
Ich freue mich auch, wie das so, ich meine, angenommen wir würden uns mal in einen maximal äh böses Regime äh deren Rolle versetzen, ja?
So, angenommen wir haben so im Wesentlichen die Kontrolle über Land und Telekommunikation. Das ist ja jetzt nicht besonders unverbreitet. Ja.
Und äh außerdem will jeder Internet haben und ich darf ihn auch noch genau vorschreiben, welches Gerät sie zu benutzen haben.
Sowas, was würde uns da einfallen? Äh ich weiß nicht, ob du diesen schönen äh Spot gesehen hast von äh Martin äh Sonneborn,
der so mit einem Präsentkorb bei Bürgern an der Tür geklopft hat und sich im Namen der Bundesregierung für die Totalüberwachung entschuldigt hat.
Und dann irgendwie noch äh äh reinmarschiert ist und noch eine Kamera äh im Wohnzimmer herausholt, also aus einer Tasche herausholt und die so ins Wohnzimmerregal stellt, ob denn das okay wäre, dass sie jetzt hier äh die Kamera hinstellen würden und so.
Und äh so praktische Tipps gegeben hat mit, naja, ist alles kein Problem, wenn sie sich privat unterhalten wollen, dann gehen sie halt einfach ins Bad und lassen sie das Wasser laufen.
Und dann so dieser entsetzte äh Blick von diesen Bürgern, die dann irgendwie nur ganz verstohlen, meinen so, äh ja, aber das mit der Kamera, das wollen wir aber jetzt eigentlich nicht und so, ja, also diese Unterwürfigkeit von normalen Menschen, das,
also da fasst man sich ja eh Art Kopf. So, um jetzt mal meine Verschwörungstheorie abzuschließen.
Da stellt mir also sozusagen das Regime ein elektronisches Gerät, was mit dem Internet verbunden ist, in meine Wohnung.
Ja.
Ja, also äh ja, die Stasi hätte ihre Freude gehabt, ja, also da muss man noch nicht mal mehr die Mikrofone unter der Tapete verlegen, ja, sondern man stellt es halt einfach direkt dahin.
Weil ne? Mikrofone sind klein und fast nicht mehr zu entdecken heutzutage, schon gar nicht in integrierten Schaltungen, also viel Spaß, sage ich nur.
Das waren dann schon übrigens auch er äh ich bin da gerade, ich habe mich nie so wirklich mit mit Telefonie auseinandergesetzt, ne, aber das Entscheidende war doch auch bei den äh bei den ähm.
Bei den analogen Telefonen, dass du sie auseinanderbauen konntest und feststellen konntest, dass der.
Schalter, wenn du auflegst, tatsächlich die Verbindung.
Getrennt hat.
Zum Mikrofon physikalisch getrennt hat, sodass es nicht möglich war, dass die Anschlussstelle
irgendwie das reinsteckt und deinen Raum überwacht. Und bei den ISDN Telefon war es so, dass es nicht mehr der Fall ist, weil das alles digital ist und es zumindest nicht ähm mit mit äh einfachen
ähm Wau Holland, Bordmitteln, in Form eines Phasenprüferschrauben-Treas, äh feststellbar war, dass dieses Mikrofon an deinem Telefon jetzt tatsächlich äh aus ist und nicht aufzeichnen kann.
Ja, zumal ist auch ein Funktions äh Grundlage äh ist, dass dieses Gerät immer mit dem Netz verbunden ist und immer mit ihm sprechen kann und das auch immer tut so. Also sozusagen, man man kann da gar nichts physikalisch trennen, dann würde es nicht mehr funktionieren so.
Die schöne Eleganz eines analogen Telefons äh an der Stelle. Na ja,
Bin mir sicher, der russische Geheimdienst, der äh hat auch schon wieder einen Dreh, Hubdreher und äh Wahlscheibentelefone im Einsatz, wo sie ist, wo sie auch schon Schreibmaschinen äh angeschafft haben.
Ja ey früher war das besser.
Früher war alles besser. So, äh wo wir gerade bei Geheimdiensten äh äh sind,
bin mir sicher, dass sie ihrer äh Aktivität jetzt während des Wahlkampfs nicht eingeschränkt haben, nennenswert.
Nee, also es gab wieder einige Meldungen aus dem aus dem Geheimdienstbereich. Ich äh übergebe die jetzt ein bisschen kürzer einfach nur, behandeln die nur kurz. Und zwar wurde bei dem,
äh hat der belgische, die belgische Telekommunikationsanbieter Belger kommen ähm.
Tief verwurzelt in seinem System gefunden oder,
äh finden lassen von FOX IT übrigens, interessanterweise, ja? Wer erinnern uns an äh äh Fox IT, die ähm,
holländische äh IT Security Bude, deren äh zweifelhafter äh Ruf zum Eklat bei der äh beim Omecamp äh führte. Äh diese äh.
Ohne Zweifel, sehr fegen äh Leute, haben sich bei bei Belger kommen.
Also quasi ein Bot Net, in deren äh Netzwerkchor äh entdeckt. Und äh.
Also Belger kommen ist ein Mobilfunkunternehmen oder generell auch Netzbetreiber äh Festnetzbetreiber.
Festnetz in dem Fall.
Ausschließlich.
Nicht ausschließlich, was die, was die äh vermutlich haben die beides, wie wie jeder Große. Also ist der Große. In diesem Fall ging es aber, glaube ich.
Festnetz. Mhm.
Um das Festnetz, denn.
Sie haben eine Tochter namens Bicks. Frag mich jetzt nicht genau wofür BICS steht. Bigs. Ähm und zu deren, die sind quasi so Hold Sale Anbieter für Netz.
Ja, also bei denen kriegst, wenn du sagst, ich brauche mal Netz, dann seien die ja hier, hast du Netz. Ne? Und zu deren Kunden zählen so Swift, äh viele wichtige, große äh belgische Unternehmen.
Äh die NATO, äh das die europäische Kommission und das Europäische Parlament ähm.
Und ähm das NATO- äh Luftkommando äh in Ramstein äh Deutschland ähm.
Die nutzen alle Bix-Infrastruktur.
Ja? Und dieser diese Bude, Belger kommen und an offensichtlich oder an so sieht's aus, auch Bigs waren irgendwie in frittiert von einer äh von einer äh großen Targetit äh Kampagne.
Und dahinter scheint das äh GCHQ, also die Briten äh gesteckt zu haben und viel mehr Genaueres weiß man jetzt nicht. Es wurden nur
Also über die politischen Verstrickungen weiß man nicht viel und es gab da nur ein äh äh Bericht darüber, äh welchen Aufwand äh Fox IT zur Detektion und zur Entfernung,
äh dieser Infektion getrieben hat, der dann technisch sehr interessant war, ähm.
Und ähm ja, wie gesagt, aus äh GCAQ Folien ging dann halt noch hervor, dass äh also aus dem Snowdenfundus gewonnenen äh GCIQ Folien ging dann eben noch hervor, ja,
Dahinter stecken die Briten oder die Briten haben auf jeden Fall großes Interesse an äh Belger gehabt.
Ja, klingt ja auch durchaus wie.
Lassen die Vermutung eben naheliegen, dass sie diese gezielte Kampagne gegen äh diesen Anbieter gefunden haben, um ihn zu infilieren.
Ja, kleines Detail äh dazu. Belger kommen äh International Carriers.
Äh was Bigs heißt. Äh unter anderem äh sind sie auch für das TAT vierzehn äh Submarin Cable äh zuständig.
Was ja vom äh GCA, wie wir hier schon mehrfach berichtet haben, äh auch ordentlich abge äh lauscht wird. Also das äh scheint mir schon ein sehr wertvolles Ziel zu sein.
Das ist ein, das ist ein unglaublicher Angriff. Ich bin da sehr gespannt auf auf mehr Details.
Ähm die werden wir sicherlich auch bekommen. Das ist sowas von.
Also das sind ja wirklich Alptraum. Das sind ja dann nur noch so wirklich diese Alptraumangriffe, von denen man äh ja, von denen man eigentlich,
denen man vielleicht selbst als paranoider kaum rechnet, äh dass man sagt, man geht ja vielleicht davon aus, dass derjenige Anbieter selbst äh da überall dranhängt, aber dass dann eben.
Ähm selbst die Geheimdienste von Verbündeten,
ähm Angriffe äh darauf fahren, äh die also, das ist dann mehrfach betont, denen alle Administrations äh Rechte und Zugänge auf dieses Netz äh gewährt haben. Wenn man sich das äh.
Also das, ja, da, das sind Dinge, da rechne, habe selbst ich nicht mitgerechnet. Dass sowas in dem Stil tatsächlich passiert,
allem bei Verbündeten, ne, man würde, wenn jetzt die Meldung gewesen wäre, ja, Berger kommen, äh analysiert alles, was sie da haben und teilt das als äh,
Geheimdienst Info mit äh mit mit den Verbündeten. Ja gut, dann hätte ich gesagt, ja, das passt ins Bild, ne. Aber dieser Angriff ähm.
Denn auf europäische Kommission. Ne, das hatten wir ja schon, diese Angriffe, auf deren einzelne Telefonswitches, die sie im Hause haben, aber dann auch den anzugreifen.
Ja, also ich meine, dass dass Britannien äh äh das Festland schon im Prinzip immer wie Ausland behandelt hat, das ist ja in dem Sinne nichts.
Na, es ist ja Ausland. Also von Britannien aus ist das Festlands Ausland.
Ja, aber feindliches Ausland.
Offensichtlich behandeln die alles was Ausland ist als Feind. Ich denke das ist.
Außer den USA.
Werden wir mal sehen, vielleicht fällt Ihnen da auch noch was.
Also das ist eine ein sehr krasser Angriff, der da jetzt äh entdeckt und verifiziert wurde.
Dann gab's jetzt äh eine Anfrage eines US-Senators, der sich mal für das Fehlverhalten der NSA-Mitarbeiter äh interessiert hat und äh für seine Anfrage dann als Antwort erhielt. Es gäbe also,
seit zweitausenddrei zwölf dokumentierte Fälle von Missbrauch,
ähm und da sind dann so schöne Figuren bei, wie das einer da an seinem ersten Arbeitstag erstmal ähm,
sechs Exfreundinnen äh kontrolliert.
Seit dem ersten Arbeitstag.
Am ersten Halbzeit, die haben gesagt, hier guck mal, hier ist dein Computer und dann hat der gesagt, oh, mal ausprobieren,
und hat der erstmal seine seine äh Exfreundin alle durchgeprüft, deren E-Mails, ja? Und andere, die also einfach grundsätzlich dann so ihre äh Lebensgefährten äh und deren Kontakte überwacht haben, ja?
Also weißt du so der Freundinnen einfach mal morgens aufm Screen, ne, dann weißt du schon, ob da irgendwie, ob da alles seine Ordnung hat, ne? Nicht, dass die da irgendwie jemanden anruft und mal gucken, wen hat sie denn da angerufen? Den überwachen wir direkt mal mit.
Äh
Mann. Das ist ja wirklich dann wie bei Brasil, ne, wo ja irgendwie Sam laurie dann auch äh das Angebot in den äh auf Information zu wechseln genutzt hat, äh in dem Moment, wo er den Bedarf sah, diesen Mittel da hinterher zu äh,
spüren, in das er sich gerade verliebt hat.
In einigen seltenen Fällen führte das dann auch wohl zur disziplinarischen Maßnahmen, zum Beispiel, dass sie eine vorübergehende Lohnkürzung ähm,
in Kauf nehmen mussten, in keinem der Fälle führte das zu einer Entlassung und äh Edward Snowden äh,
betonte ja dann auch, äh in dem Zusammenhang, dass es keinerlei technische Maßnahmen gegen Missbrauch gibt. Das ist allerdings, da sieht man, da liegt schon in der Frage, äh die kann nur von einem,
Journalisten gekommen sein, denn eine technische Maßnahme ging Missbrauch ist ja auch nicht äh wirklich äh vorstellbar.
Ja ähm.
Ja, wie soll die Technik wissen, was Missbrauch ist, ne?
Ja, was sollte, ich meine, Entschuldigung, das ganze Ding ist äh missbraucht, dass dieses System ist ein Missbrauch von Daten. So, das ganze Ding ist Missbrauch. Wenn wir jetzt die technische ähm,
technische Maßnahme wäre, also das Ausschalten dieses kompletten Überwachungssystems, ja, aber sonst äh ist da nichts äh nix denkbar, was da, was da eine Kontrolle äh sinnvoller Kontrollmechanismus wäre. Ähm.
Das sind also jetzt die zwölf dokumentierten Fälle, das heißt, da waren Leute, haben sich so dämlich angestellt, dass es den äh erstens aufgefallen ist und zweitens, der Sohn fast raus äh wurde, dass man das irgendwo auch dokumentieren musste, ja,
Ich denke, die Dunkelziffer derer, die nicht entdeckt sind oder derer, die entdeckt werden, aber von ihren äh Supervisors das Ganze irgendwie in einem ernsten Gespräch ohne Dokumentierung,
äh
Ähm zum Ende kommt, die Dunkelziffer ist ja sicherlich noch um einiges größer. Und dann gibt es den äh Fall in Deutschland jetzt äh des Journalisten Ronny Blaschke.
Der ein äh sich als freier Journalist somit äh Gewalt Diskriminierung und Rechtsextremismus im Sport auseinandersetzt. Das heißt, er hat äh sicherlich auch einige ähm.
Einige äh Leute, die ihn nicht besonders mögen, ne? Grade diskriminierende, rechtsextreme äh gewalttätige im Sport äh sind ja nicht selten,
Vor allem wenn man so in Richtung Fußball schaut und der bekam einen Anruf von der neuen,
niedersächsischen Verfassungsschutzpräsidentin Maren Brandenburger, die ihnen darüber in Kenntnis setzte, dass er äh vom Verfassungsschutz überwacht würde.
Und dann äh ihm kurz darauf äh fünf Zeilen sendete, dass äh die Information über ihn nach sofortiger Prüfung äh gelöscht worden seien. Und sie hat ihn wohl nur am Telefon ähm,
angedeutet, dass es eventuell damit zu tun haben könnte, dass er einen Vortrag über seine äh Recherchen bei der Partei DIE LINKE äh.
Hat, ne? Partei, die jetzt, glaube ich, ungefähr zehn Prozent bei der Bundestagswahl geholt hat und erst ja, ungefähr zehn. Und äh vom Verfassungsschutz überwacht wird, ja?
Im Gegensatz zu anderen Parteien, bei denen man es vielleicht mal auch machen könnte.
Also äh der deutsche Niedersächsische ist noch nicht mal der äh also der die Landesbehörde äh Verfassung für Verfassungsschutz Niedersachsen ähm.
Überwacht ein Journalisten, der über Rechtsextreme Diskriminierung und Gewalt schreibt. Ja, das zeigt ungefähr,
in welcher äh welche Geisteshaltung da anscheinend immer noch vorherrscht in dem Bundesamt und Landesämtern für Verfassung.
Na, selber Schuld? Was hält er auch Vorträge bei den äh Linken, da muss man doch wissen, dass äh dass dass das nicht äh gut sein kann.
Das ist ähm also man man hat da natürlich der kommt, genau dieser äh dieser klassische äh in den Sinn,
Ne, auf dem auf dem rechten Auge blind die Verfassungs äh Schutzbehörden inlandsgeheimdienste und äh so die sich immer,
den Extremismus immer links vermuten und sich da sehr viel drum kümmern, während äh Nazibanden in Deutschland äh über Jahre äh unbehelligt morden können.
Ähm und das lässt ja auch so ein bisschen, also es gibt ja relativ viel auch so geschichtliche Reportage und so zum Bundesamt für Verfassung, Verfassungschutz und seinen seinen,
aus seinen politischen Ausrichtungen. Und da habe ich vor Kurzem eine äh sehr interessante Folge die neueste Folge des,
Metrolaut Podcasts gehört. Metronaut, Metrolaut neunzehn über Berufsverbote, Staatsschutz und Extremismus mit dem Historiker,
Dominik Riegol, das klingt jetzt erstmal relativ trocken,
Aber das war eine äh sehr interessante Episode. Ähm der hat seine Dissertation eben darüber geschrieben,
wie das dann so in den siebziger Jahren war mit den mit den Berufsverboten für Menschen die irgendwie in 'ner,
Friedensbewegung waren, weil man sie jetzt irgendwie für Kommunisten hielt und deswegen nicht in den Staatsdienst übernehmen wollte. Und äh wieder so vorgegangen wurden, dass natürlich die
Verwebungen mit dem Verfassungsschutz sind da natürlich sehr groß, denn der hat ja die Datenbasis für diese Berufsverbote geliefert. Lege ich also,
ans Herz, sich diese Episode mal anzuhören. Ist auch verlinkt.
Ja, sieht sehr interessant aus, vor allem mal so ein kompletter geschichtlicher äh Rap-Up von dem Ganzen ähm Thema, das äh hat man ja auch nicht überall.
Gut Linus, ich glaube, wir haben's, oder? Das ist jetzt äh eine etwas längere Sendung geworden.
Ja, ich hatte gar nicht damit gerechnet, dass wir uns alle gut halten, aber ich war, ich fand die Sendung, glaube ich, ganz gut. Ich bin ganz.
Ja, war mal Zeit, auch grad mal so diese Wahl äh auch ein bisschen zu verdauen, weil.
Und ja, wir hoffen, dass wir hier trotz der etwas schwierigen Vernetzungssituation, äh in der du dich gerade befindest, hier noch eine ordentliche Audioqualität abgeliefert haben, denn das ist ja wichtig, ne?
Ja. Ansonsten ist auch vorne geschult.
Genau.
Und ich möchte noch, ich möchte noch ein paar äh letzte Worte äh in Anbetracht dieser dieser Wahl loswerden. Ähm.
Es ist natürlich auch für für uns ein äh oder für mich zumindest ist das schon eine ernüchternde ähm.
Eine ernüchternde Erkenntnis, dass also all diese Themen, die wir hier äh mit diesem äh behandeln und wo wir uns immer sehr Mühe geben,
Ja, vielleicht ähm,
aufgeklärte Propaganda zu betreiben, vor allem in den letzten Folgen sind wir ja da durchaus auch mal ein bisschen schärfer gewesen, als wir das vielleicht in den in den siebzig Folgen davor so gemacht haben.
Ähm und ich bin jetzt schon etwas enttäuscht, dass diese Themen irgendwie in der äh in der Bundespolitik offensichtlich so.
Wenig seine kleine Rolle gespielt haben, wobei ich erhoffe, dass wir hier die Überzeugungsarbeit leisten, dass diese Themen alles andere als unbedeutend sind.
Und äh das betrügt mich. Und deshalb äh werbt werbt für Logbuch Netzpolitik,
werbt für die Netzbewegung, werbt äh für Unterstützer, für die äh,
äh äh NGO eurer Wahl, ja, da möchte ich jetzt gar nicht ein, welcher das ist, aber ähm.
Ja, vielleicht äh schafft ihr es, dass das Evangelium äh der Freiheit ein bisschen weiter zu tragen und uns vielleicht noch ein paar mehr Hörer äh zu empfehlen, die wir indok trainieren können und so.
Ja, ich denke nicht so sehr, dass das jetzt eine Frage der Indoor-Trination ist, sondern man kann ja
mal hier so ganz wie so ein ähm wie wie ein guter Wahlverlierer, ja äh bedankt man sich halt trotzdem erstmal bei den Wählerinnen und Wählern, äh ja, die trotz äh allem da die Unterstützung äh gezeigt haben und vor allem übt man Einsicht, ja? Und schaut mal äh und erkennt mal an
dass vielleicht eben die eigene Themenwelt nicht alles darstellt. Und ich denke, das wäre auch sehr vermessen bei diesem doch sehr äh kantigen, schwierig zu verstehen, denn äh Themenkomplex. Vielleicht ist Netzpolitik als solches einfach noch nicht
ähm profiliert genug. Vielleicht wird es das auch niemals sein, äh seinen eigenständigen Themenkatalog
äh aufzurufen, seitdem genug Leute sich äh versammeln können, sagen können, oh, das ist mir jetzt aber mal genauso wichtig wie äh Steuern, ja? Ich meine
allein eine Steuerdiskussion, alles was mit Arbeitsmarkt zu tun hat et cetera, das ist das eine, ja? Ich meine, da ist eine CDU äh äh die jetzt ähm durchaus mit einer Verhältnismäßig äh starken äh Wirtschaftsleistung des Landes werben kann, äh nicht schlecht dasteht, sollte auch keinen überraschen.
Ja, das ist einfach äh für so eine Bundestagswahl sind einfach so viele Themen wichtig, traditionell, ja?
Dass äh es schon an ein Wunder grenzt, dass irgendwie ein Nischenthema da wirklich durchschlägt.
Dinge, die mal ein Nischenthema waren, ja, können das irgendwann mal auch mal tun
sowie ähm Fukushima äh jetzt die Wahl in Baden-Württemberg nachhaltig beeinflusst hat, ja, sieht man ja auch, dass das jetzt nicht unbedingt eine dauerhafte Tendenz ist für die Grünen, die sich dort abgezeichnet hat
das hat aber dann eben auch erstmal so zwanzig Jahre gedauert fünfundzwanzig Jahre bis seit wirklich
das Thema sagen wir mal so, auch verankert ist in der Gesellschaft, ja?
Leute, die mit Umweltpolitik groß geworden oder mit diesen Anfängen der Umweltpolitik groß geworden sind, die sind halt jetzt erst äh im im Besitzstandswahrer äh äh Alter angekommen. So und
machen wir uns nix vor, ja, der ganze Digitalkram ist einfach noch sehr neu, nach wie vor.
Der entwickelt sich aber zu schnell. Ich habe das ja schon vor einigen Folgen mal gesagt, so die die Weichen, in welche Richtung sich dieser ganze Netzkram entwickelt, werden jetzt gestellt und nicht erst in zwanzig Jahren.
Was jetzt, wenn wir diese ganze Netzneutralitätsnummer jetzt auf internationalem Niveau nennenswert verlieren, ja, dann wird der Weg zurück,
insbesondere jetzt in der Zeitspanne von zwanzig Jahren, ein sehr, sehr viel beschwerlicherer. Ja, deswegen bleibe ich schon so ein bisschen dabei, also diese dieses Bild von einer äh da in in diesem Fall ist nicht.
Allzu ähm allzu weit her, ja? Also es ist schon ja, ich gehe also davon aus, dass sich das,
Wir haben's jetzt auch gesehen, wie wie politische Entwicklung ähm in diesem Bereich, wie viele, ja, also ich meine, dieses ganze Themenfeld Netzpolitik ist doch grade mal etwas mehr als zehn Jahre alt. Also äh Internetpolitik, ja. Ähm und hat erst seit,
Also das ist jetzt wirklich zum Politikthema wurde, ist doch gerade mal zehn Jahre alt. Und ähm.
Fünf Jahre würde ich eher sagen.
Ja, ich sage jetzt zehn Jahre, weil Netzpolitik Org bald zehn Jahre alt wird und deswegen sage ich jetzt zehn.
Ja gut, das äh was einige Leute das gesehen haben, aber das ist, sagen wir mal, überhaupt erstmal auf dem Feld da war, ist klar, ne? Wir haben.
Okay, aber sagen wir das relevante, gesellschaftliche Entscheidung in diesem Bereich stattfinden? Okay, fünf Jahre, ja? Seit zweitausendacht, zweitausendneun oder.
Ja und das ist nichts. Das ist nicht mal, das ist gerade mal so eine Legislaturperiode.
Ist nix. Und jetzt überleg mal, was wir alles schon für eine Scheiße haben, ja.
Ich würd mal sagen digitaler Klimawandel
Ja, also wir haben jetzt hier sozusagen ein langfristige äh Entwicklung, die sich abzeichnet. Manche verstehen es halt und mahnen und rufen und sagen und wedeln mit den Armen und sagen, Leute, äh habt ihr sie noch alle? Äh der der Mires äh Spiegel äh steigt, ja
und äh äh so ist es halt äh in gewisser Hinsicht auch auf so ein Bürgerrechtslevel.
Ja, Tim, aber eigentlich wollte ich nur darauf hinweisen, dass ich ein Amazon-Wunschzettel habe.
Den verlinken wir natürlich auch Linus.
Auf Wiederhören.
Auf Wiedersehen. Das war's. Bis bald. Tschüss.